candid
truth Hello everybody welcome back to
candid Truth where the truth is not an
option but it is a standard I hope you
guys are ready for what is to come
there's a lot and it's okay a lot of
what you will hear is thing are things
that you guys don't even know about it's
many many many new holidays that are
hidden in the occult or otherwise
um so thank you all for being here we're
excited to dive in and just buckle up
because here we
go all right let's
go so we're going to go through a little
bit of
recapping um there's a holiday
specifically in April
that I didn't get to cover in fact I
missed it because it was given a
different name in The Occult so let's go
back just a minute all right so this for
anyone's reference is what we're
covering eventually this is part two let
me go back and and talk to you guys here
it's part two of three um number three
will be coming soon I do it at as soon
as I can but life is crazy um so let's
dive into this you can go ahead and take
a screenshot of the timeline just to
have it in mind I'll try to do my best
but let's do that
overview
oops all right so we have to rewind a
bit
um so this is what we're covering all of
it in total when we get to part three
we'll get to the very end right now
we're covering April a little bit of
April again to overview and then we're
going back all the way to August
okay all right so to
review we missed strove tide this might
be a completely new holiday to you guys
um I certainly had never heard about it
before and it is let's see
here it is actually
on wow it's 3 days before Ash Wednesday
that's amazing okay so that's where I'm
getting it is from the legend in the
corner in the right so let's read about
this they have shove tide Saturday which
starts with
processions and it has some elements
that oh I want to talk to you guys about
because you're going to recognize it
right away once we start to address it
so in Italy France Germany they have
Carnival season which has parades
masquerades and elaborate
costumes participants wear vibrant
attire and masks engaging in a spirit of
rry and social role reversal before
lent's period of
fasting this is directly taken from
saturnalia if you ever heard that or if
that rings a bell I did address that
last
time so they also have folk traditions
this is in Slovenia where they actually
do this for shrob
tide um I'm not going to try to say that
name but it involves unmarried
men dressing in colorful costumes and
traditional masks traveling door too to
collect small gifts these folk
processions often featuring symbolic
characters like a bride and groom
remember that because you're going to
need it next next time we
speak they are meant to bring good luck
and welcome the upcoming spring number
three community feasts and pancakes now
this actually this whole time period
that we're going to be speaking about
right now is has a lot to do with
pancakes so um Unfortunately they are
not pure but hey I love a good
pancake so it's not bad you don't just
throw out the baby with the bath
water in this community feast and
pancake time again that's number three
we're on it says United in the United
Kingdom Community Gatherings featured
foods like pancakes and pastries using
up using up ingredients like eggs butter
and
milk um that are typically abstained
from during Lent so if you guys I don't
know your background or
anything but you have to give up so many
things during
Lent
that this was normal this was
tradition you had to go ahead and stain
from everything give all those things up
make your pancakes out of them to get
them out of the house before
lent so number four symbolic farewell to
Winter in
Slovenia they have current features
figures sorry which is dressing in hides
and adorned with horns so this to me
rang a bell uh mainly
because you know how they have furries
today people dressing up in
in costumes that are furry like animals
this seemed similar they parade through
neighborhoods to symbolically chase away
winter spirits and invite the fertility
of
spring
okay so there's shro tide Saturday that
is just what we've covered now go with
me to the next day shro tide
Sunday it's also called oh my goodness
qua all right I'm not going to try that
anyway a time for special church
services and family gatherings in
anticipation of Lent this is blessings
and spiritual PR preparation many attend
Services focused on forgiveness
spiritual renewal and prep uh
preparation for the upcoming fasting
season so they would feast and have
fellowship with their families having a
big meal Rich dishes to use up
everything in the house so that they
would be able to fast better during Lent
then you have
shro oh I'm sorry colop Monday a day
before shove Tuesday so if you get the
gist there is shro Saturday shro Sunday
um colop Monday and shro
Tuesday
so
um let's follow through with what call
up Monday
is in addition to fasting there is
particular note in the region of the UK
to have colop feasts traditional dishes
featuring cops which are slices of meat
especially
bacon and the meal is thought to be to
use up fatty
ingredients that would be abstained from
during Lent this would also be
butter so it also is very variable
during different uh periods around the
world when it's kept in different
regions basically
in some areas on this day they also
feature smaller folk
processions or family gatherings in
preparation for the main shove Tuesday
event okay so shro
Tuesday is actually the main Pancake
Day
um I don't know it's just crazy to hear
that pancakes are a part of this so the
final and most widely celebrated day of
shove tide is shove Tuesday Pancake Day
they had pancake races and
feasts such as in the United Kingdom and
other countries pancake races were held
in many towns with participants flipping
pancakes and frying pans while racing
pancakes are traditionally eaten as a
way to use up rich ingredients before
fasting okay so I have a note there this
is actually a practice of the Goddess
Hestia or Vesta
if you haven't heard of them already
please go ahead and check out several of
my other presentations she is um a major
goddess who has to do with baking
cakes not necessarily just a cake but
that's part of worshiping her just like
um the Queen of Heaven in the
Bible um and so here the pancakes are
tied to her okay so there's Carnival
parades and final festivities
which is where Carnival is
celebrated to me this is kind of um some
of the ancient festivals they had had
Carnival undertones but this one seems
to highlight it pretty
well and shro on shro Tuesday it marks
the last day of grand parades and
festivities Italy's Venice Carnival
Brazil's Rio Carnival and Germany's
Carnival
wow reach their Peak with vibrant
displays of costumes and music Saturn
this relates to Saturn and burning man
wicker or straw man Effigy
burning
okay so that should sound like Marty gr
you guys it's kind of what it
is so some regions hold final
processions or symbolic farewell rituals
to Mark the end of the festivities sign
if Ying the transition to lent which is
actually called a Celtic St
bridg day again if you haven't seen the
first holiday presentation and you don't
know who St Bridget is yet go back and
watch it please and you'll then know
what I'm talking
about so number four Community
Gatherings and final feasts friends and
family come together one last time
before lent to enjoy festive dishes
often including rich or indulgent Foods
as part of the
tradition okay so this is what it would
pretty much look like you have the
Burning Man Effigy you have the statue
of Vesta you have the the race running
from One Direction you've everybody
eating pancakes that's what it would
look like this is a a picture depicting
it more of the Roman or Greek persuasion
from ancient
times okay let's go to a full screen
here so another note about shro tide
Tuesday is it believe it or not had
football attached to
it the Royal shro Tide football games
were played annually on Trove Tuesday
and Ash Wednesday in the town of Ash
Ashburn uh derbish Shire
England is another traditional practice
associated with the broader
shro tide
festivities although it's not directly
tied to the Feast of St George the game
shares roots with medieval Customs that
incorporated Community Gatherings and
symbolic battles or competitions as part
of pre-lent
activities
so this is when parts of the Royal shro
Tide football had in
it Community symbolic battles if you
will
and the game will pit two teams against
each other one would be called the
upwards and the other downwards based on
where players lived in relation to the
town's
River that's just
weird um but then they're pitted against
each other in a symbolic battle that can
involve hundreds of players over a large
field which is supposed to symbolize the
whole town the game symbolizes RI
rivalry and Community cohesion echoing
the competitive spirit seen in ancient
seasonal games and rituals that took
place during shove tide and other
festivals the game shares roots with
medieval Customs that incorporated
Community Gatherings and symbolic
battles or competitions as part of
pre-lent
activities okay the Royal shro Tide
football game and modern Super Bowl
here's the connection to today they
share some fascinating parallels
so they ritualize competition and social
celebration though they originate from
vastly different context and historical
timelines here the
connections so both the shro tide game
and the Super Bowl hold deep
significance for the representative
communities in Ashburn The shro Tide
football game is an annual event that
brings a whole town together with locals
divided into two teams upwards and
downwards based on
geography similarly the so a Super Bowl
gathers American communities and fans
Nationwide with strong Regional support
for the competing
teams the Royal shove Tide football game
is more than just a game it's a physical
and symbolic struggle involving the
entire town played over two
days with Loosely defined boundaries and
rules where players aim to reach their
team's goal this mirrors the spirit of
the Super Bowl where two teams engage in
a highly structured but intense
competition that channels Collective
energy and excitement a modern echo of
symbolic battles seen in ancient and
medieval
festivals
okay the shro tide game is surrounded by
local
festivities often likened to a holiday
for Ashburn simply I'm
sorry um similarly the Super Bowl has
evolved Beyond a sporting event to
include Nationwide F festivities with
watch parties commercials and halftime
performances making it a cultural
spectacle
so let's take a look deeper shro Tide
football represents a form of folk
football with medieval or even Pagan
Roots connected to community bonding and
seasonal
celebrations the Super
Bowl while
newer and professionally organized
carries forward this tradition of
ritualized sports tapping into the same
human
drive for symbolic competition unity and
celebration though they differ in origin
and scope both the Royal shro Tide
football game and the Super Bowl serve
as modern and historical
expressions of community identity
competitive spirit and Collective
celebration marking key moments
on the calendar that bring people
together in powerful symbolic
ways okay so that was our recap just to
include Marty gr and all the sh shrob
tide and pancakes and the Super Bowl
because these are key elements that we
see in our world
today so I hope that wasn't too much to
recap with but that helps us address
that and move forward so let's jump in
there
okay so this would be a depiction of of
course the Super Bowl well the strob
Tide football
games again it was always kind of
um carried out
with a statue that's supposed to be
Vesta or um
Hestia because she was likened to uh
Zeus who was worshiped in Apollo for the
Olympics and this actually came
I shouldn't say it came from the
Olympics it actually was a part of how
the Olympics was structured and came
about all right so on to April Fool's
Day I don't know if many of you like
this day but I think you'd be
surprised as to why it
exists the origins of April Fool's Day
are complex blending myth mythological
religious and cultural elements across
centuries one of the most accepted
theories tra traces to the Roman
Festival
Hilaria okay so think laughter
Hilaria celebrated around the vernal
equinox to honor the goddess
cybel again we've talked about this you
know if I I've covered something I will
always tell you what god or goddess it
worships so please go back and watch
some of my earlier videos um such as the
Rainman and androgyny there you will
learn a lot more about these gods that
I'm already
mentioning during this time participants
would wear disguises engage in playful
mischief and reverse social roles
symbolizing a temporary break into
societal
Norms key themes that resonate with
modern day April
Fool's
Customs oh this was a key theme that
resonated with modern April Fool's
customs in medieval
Europe April Fool
Traditions may have also been influenced
by the Feast of fools celebrated in
France this occasion involves fools or
Jester gestur yeah engaging in mock
rituals and reverse roles within
Cathedrals isn't this interesting we
have mocking rituals and Ro reversals
within Cathedrals all I can do is liken
that to somewhat of the humiliation
rituals that they go through in
Hollywood to make it up the
ranks
crazy leading some to believe it
eventually merged with a seasonal prank
associated with April 1st however over
time it was often mistaken for a parody
rather than a form of reverence as it
was originally intended can you believe
it why would they originally make April
Fool's Day and pranks and mock rituals
and so on with clowns everywhere pretty
much which or
gestur how would they claim that that
was reverence how is that ever supposed
to be a thing of reverence I don't
know okay so those are my sources on
that moving forward a little more about
April Fool's Day another notable
influence
came from the shift in New Year
celebrations France's 1564 Edict of
rouson I believe set January 1st as the
official start of the year but those who
continued celebrating the old New Year
and didn't switch to the Gregorian
calendar in late March became known as
April fools due to their persistence in
the previous calendar
traditions this change spread throughout
Europe
embedding pranking as a powerful way to
highlight this calendar
disagreement these diverse Origins
illustrate April Fool's Day has evolved
from a blend of ancient celebrations
Christian what they mean Christian by
the way they're meaning the Catholic
church so it's Catholic lurgical
practices and Regional Customs this
layered history becomes a fascinating
lens into the interplay between
mythology cultural Transitions and
communal celebrations that led to the
holiday as we know it
today the connection between April
Fool's Day and reverence oh wow okay
they're going to try to explain why
reverence is in here and
reverence on the last paragraph here
stems from Traditions like the medieval
French Feast of Fools and the Roman
Hilaria Feast both of which included
humor as a form of symbolic release
rather than mere mockery
during the Feast of fools lower ranking
clergy and lay people took on roles
usually held by the high clergy in a
festive role
reversal the intention wasn't
sacrilege but to celebrate humility
aligning with the biblical view that God
exalts the humble so this is a really
strange thing
okay it's kind of like hazing it's like
you have to go through these things to
to be humbled to earn your right to that
position um it doesn't sound Godly at
all it sounds more like a Jesuit
thing it's really strange anyway
continuing on the last
sentence down below says this ritualized
foolishness embodied a sense of
reverence by acknowledging joy and
gratitude through playful acts
illustrating a core spiritual
concept all right let's see what this
might look
like similarly hararia honored
cbel a revered mother deity through
joyous often humorous celebrations
emphasizing relief from life's hardships
a form of reverence through communal Joy
they
say both cele celebrations suggest that
humor and humility even if expressed
through foolish pranks or light-hearted
Customs held sacred undertones rather
than pure
ridicule okay I got to laugh at this
this is not true on any
level but
anyway last sentence again this
underscores why history I mean
historically these rituals were seen as
celebratory acts with deeper symbolic
reverence
I don't know how they're they're bending
that to become reverent or
uh
humbling
anyway continuing on the occult meaning
of this day oh this is going to get good
okay listen up you guys so it's not just
a origin coming from the King having
gestures in the Medieval ages to
supposedly have reverence
to I guess God as a Catholics would
think it was stemming from other things
too like I mentioned it's cybel but this
is going to get even
deeper okay let's take a look for those
in a cult or esoteric communities April
Fool's Day can hold symbolic
significance tied to archetypes and
seasonal Cycles rather than just
humor okay so it's like the um lunar
cycles and the the sun cycles as well
which we're not supposed to keep so it
says in Pagan and oul traditions the
fool archetype often represents
spiritual
renewal okay stepping into the unknown
and challenging
Norms Concepts that align with the
beginning of Spring a Time associated
with new life and
transformation okay that's a
stretch but it keeps going it says
trickster figures like Loki coyote and
Hermes embody these ideas using mischief
to disrupt the usual order and provoke
reflection or change which resonates
with the spirit of April Fool's
Day H especially Hermes when I looked at
it that's what my note means he was
definitely linked with this heavily more
than other gods even because he is the
god of Thieves and outlaws and even
pranks interesting huh I never would
have
thought okay so the day also relates to
ideas in alchemy where the fool quote
unquote symbolizes the
initiate the initial unrefined stage of
transformation I'm sorry it didn't say
initiate it said just initial unrefined
stage of
transformation reminding practitioners
to embrace
uncertainty and cultivate
growth some occultists and
Freemasons see a April 1st as a chance
to confront life's
absurdities pushing boundaries to
inspire self-awareness and encourage New
Perspectives huh
wow
interesting thus for some April Fool's
Day represents a blend of humor and
symbolic exploration of personal or
spiritual growth so that picture that
you see is of Hermes it says it right
there and he is known as like I said the
god of Thieves and outlaws so he has all
kinds of things there that he stole or
he kind of rules over you can look that
up further we don't have time for a lot
of that right now but let's go ahead and
get on to our next thing
here this is Earth
Day we're this is where we left off in
our covering um
all the holidays from last
time this is where we pick up from part
one this
is yeah that's where we would go to is
Earth Day so April 22nd is Earth
Day and well
um as you can see above again from the
usually a cult and satanic uh ritual
abuse calendar that I've I include a lot
it would say that that April 1st uh 21st
through the 26th is abduction ceremonial
preparation and holding of sacrificial
victims so the 22nd would of course
follow within that
range and this is why it
exists the modern celebration of Earth
Day while secular and environmentally
focused reflects a deep rooted human
tradition of reverence for nature
growth and the cyclical renewal of life
these themes resonate with ancient Pagan
and mythological practices from various
cultures which honored the earth and its
seasonal changes through gods goddesses
and symbolic
rituals here's a summary of the
connections so first we have as you
might have
thought um it is of course
ostara or
Easter which is the Spring Equinox and
of course location or it um proximity to
Easter kind of tips you
off so spring equinox which is to ostara
or
Easter the goddess ostara by the
way is celebrated by Celtic and Germanic
pagans the Spring Equinox honors o
oester or ostara which is actually
Ishtar or Easter a goddess associated
with the
dawn for ility and New Life her Festival
symbolizes the Earth's renewal planting
and growth Earth st's timing around
early spring Echoes the celebration of
life emerging from
Winter that's what they think
anyway so Earth Day if you haven't heard
is truly another name for Ishtar or
Mother Earth would be
Gaia Gaia is the ancient Greek goddess
of the earth and is often associated
with Earth
Day okay
so all right it's linked with
ishar and Gaia now but who is Gaia Gaia
is the personification of the earth and
the mother of many other gods she is
considered
one of the earliest Elemental deities
created at the beginning of
time Gaia symbolizes a nurturing
sustaining force of abundance and
Limitless giving how is Guy Associated
well H many people refer to
her as Mother Earth and guy is the
goddess of the Earth the idea that the
Earth is alive may be as old as
humankind and the Greeks viewed the
Earth as a living
organism all right so this came from
a a pagan origin a pagan resource and
they say there are certain ways to
connect with Gaia at this time of of the
year um on Earth Day you can walk
Barefoot on the earth ground yourself to
Mother Earth do a sun salute on your
deck so that's yoga breathe in the
spring air which all right we we aren't
trying to get close to Gaia or worship
her but we are fine with breathing in
clean
air practicing savasana lying on the
Earth from from what I know
um savasana is related to yoga so um not
really a great thing
either so this is also linked with a
multitude of mother goddesses um
nurturing goddesses like Gaia teramat
and tus which is a Roman name for teram
moer and nerus which is
dramaic these deities are wor seen as
the source of all
life and rituals were held in the honor
in their honor to ensure the land's
fertility Earth day's focus on
protecting and nurturing the planet is a
continuation of the respect shown to
these Earth
deities the green man oh my goodness
okay have you guys heard of green man
it's okay you see him you usually on
Garden
Gates or walls or just in gardens really
because he
represents um the Earth and Greenery and
Lush like like Gaia does too so the
green man um let's continue
reading the Green Man a figure seen in
European folklore represents the spirit
of
vegetation life and rebirth often
depicted with leaves and Vines you'll
get to see a picture of him by the way
very soon we're going to go over these
Gods the Green Man embodies Humanity's
connection to Nature and the renewal of
the earth seems that align closely with
Earth day's
purpose so number one the mythological
connections number one is Egyptian
mythology in Egypt GB was the god of the
earth associated with growth and
vegetation Additionally the myth of
Osiris and Isis which centers on death
and Resurrection which symbolizes the
life cycles mirrored in nature earth
days themes of regeneration and life
cycles resonate with these ancient
Egyptian
beliefs all right oh here we go very
good
so you can see Green Man in the up uh
the right hand corner there's two
pictures of him of course you see the
one in stone probably on a wall in a
garden of course and then you see a just
an image of him drawn that way with
leaves okay and this
is oh down below the Egyptian god is GB
the one we just talked about and the
next one to it with the goat horns and
the
green body which is also has the Egypt
kind Egyptian
um let's see that Egyptian beard thing
that he straps on is also GB
so the two Down Below in this picture on
this slide is
GB and then the one in the middle which
is a mother with two it looks like a
woman with two kids is Tellus from Rome
the one with the Cornucopia in her hand
is teram
Mater okay so Earth Day this is where we
get a little
deeper as most of you might might have
understood you know these things come
from like
Babylonian um Origins as well and in
Babylonian Customs this would come from
the god Tiamat representing primordial
chaos and the elemental forces of
creation while eia or enki known by both
names was the god of wisdom and water it
was connected to fertility and the
Earth's life lifegiving
aspects the these figures emphasize the
balance between Chaos and Order and
Humanity's role in sustaining creation
Concepts that reflect Earth day's call
for environmental
stewardship huh interesting okay caldan
beliefs which are even more kind of
deeper rooted uh mystery beliefs of the
Babylonians they had n
nerta a god of Agriculture and
Marduk I hope that that rings a bell
Marduk is Kash or B
um of course he has other names but he
is supposed to have shaped the heavens
and
earth they were both revered for their
roles in creating and maintaining
natural order and
fertility Earth days focus on nurturing
the environment aligns with these
deities symbolic associations with
cultivation and life cycles now we go on
to Roman mythology this would include
series hope I'm saying that right um
when they celebrated celebrated her the
goddess of agriculture and grain they
would do so with a serola feast so this
would be where we get the word
serial because she is the goddess of
grain does that ring a bell to anyone is
that interesting to anyone
else it's so
weird but this emphasizes planting and
growth tus who is also teram moer or
Mother Earth was honored in the for
cidia fora cidia to secure crop
fertility while Flora goddess of the
flowers and plants was celebrated in the
FL
floral floralia
floralia wow I can't say
that anyway with festivals that
celebrated Nature's Beauty these Roman
gods and their festivals resonate
strongly with the Earth with Earth day's
encouragement of planting environmental
Beauty and the respect for
Earth all right it's
mouthful so let's talk about who this
is we'll start on the right top right
and top bottom is actually series again
this is the goddess of
grain and
um this is where we get cereal from and
the festival
Celia then we have Flor she is next to
series she's holding the lay of flowers
and next to her is Tiamat the Babylonian
God who is a snake half snake half human
person who is over order in chaos I hope
that rings a bell as well because Order
and Chaos is more a theme of the
oul you hear it from the um Jesuits and
from the
Illuminati and you would probably find
that with Satanist as well Alistar
Crowley certainly talks about
this but she was featured as a dragon a
lot of the time that is why she has a
tail it's either a snake or a dragon and
down below down below
her we see this Dragon which is
her um in a
picture which opposite of her shows
Flora they're not fighting or anything
they just for some reason uh decided to
depict Tiamat with flora and how
different they
are then we have what was the other
God that we
missed um the next God that we're
missing
is
enki I had to go check so this is en key
that we see on the left the very left
down below on the bottom and the top he
is the god of fish and the water and he
said have made humankind which is
interesting but you can see his
Babylonian Origins with a beard and the
shells and his
staff so yeah he's um kind of
crazy so Earth Day again it has tree
worship and Groves associated with
it and this would be interesting to know
why tree worship was integral in many
ancient Pagan cultures especially Among
The Druids so now we bring in the very
oul Origins here who revered trees as
sacred planting trees and nurturing
forests as emphasized on Earth Day
mirrors these ancient wrs where trees
were seen as symbols of life and were
often planted in sacred
Groves the burning or symbolic cleansing
of winter is associated with it as well
within ancient traditions in parts of
Germany and Slavic regions it involves
the burning of winter quote unquote
through Effigies or figures such as the
curent in Slovenia and straw figures in
ger Germanic cultures to chase away
winter and be and welcome
spring so that they just told us exactly
why the Burning Man
happens that ties it to it and a lot of
these holidays when they're next to each
other they do have a lot of um
connected symbols or um
meaning so this is where that comes from
it's a much Clear answer of
why this notion of clearing away the old
to make way for Renewal aligns with
Earth day's call for environmental
action and
renewal so if we think about the tree
and the Druid religion
here we will see that you know in cabala
we have the
tree the cabala tree um of the steps in
which you are to work your way up the
orders and the gods to become God
yourself that's also in Freemasonry in
um the Jesuit world if you get really
deep into it um if you really look at a
lot of different religions they're doing
the same thing and so are the occultists
they're really doing that as well so
that tree is supposed to symbolize like
all of that it's
um really
crazy so let's go back to our notes and
see what's
next ah okay so on Earth Day they have
certain things that the witches say to
do of
course to um probably venerate or
celebrate Gaia earth the earth
mother so number
one let's let's do ourselves favor favor
and try to read that a little better try
it says a one day Zero waste Challenge
and reflect on your experience in your
grimoire okay a grimoire is a cast spell
book I'm sorry that witches use so you
put this in your
book and you do a zero waste challenge
which by the way zero waste is great we
all actually should be stewards of the
earth better but when they use this to
worship gods and put that as the reason
instead of taking care of the earth um
because God made it and we need to take
care of it better then
we're worshiping other gods um
deceptively but we all should care about
theirs so that's not a bad
thing but they want you to put this in
your book of
spells it says add a globe or Global
image to your altar to promote a think
globally act locally
attitude okay number three dedicate the
cleanup of an outdoor space to your
preferred deity ancestors animal
allies or Spirit of the
land H okay that's getting a little
creepy there spiritual guides and stuff
number four celebrate or decorate a bin
with paint and stencils and begin your
sacred composting practice
okay don't get me wrong
um this is
weird I love gardening and composting of
course as we know is a good
practice it's not evil at all but wicens
and the cult world are quite good at
repurposing crafts and activities for
worshiping Gods um by being resourceful
and use like using the things that the
Earth has given you you're kind of
giving honor back to it so that's not
what we want to do but of course we
would have no purpose
um to be angry at people who are
composting we would want to do the same
just to clarify that for
others okay let's go
back number
five access where our witchy supplies
come
from are they gathered to ensure
sustainable
harvests it is time to consider
alternatives how can you get creative
with recycled resources so recycling
Again by the way did anyone think about
this as the climate change push that is
going to be
um yeah pushed on us in the end
days because that's a connection there
number six consult your favorite
divination method and ask for guidance
about your personal mission an
actionable inspiration for Earth
stewardship record any inspiration and
take action as soon as possible number
seven choose a plant Ally to bring into
your home is a reminder of Earth
Consciousness okay so that's like an
altar putting an item on your altar to
remember to do things or to worship
that's like your item that worships Gaia
on it you have one for many other gods
on your altar but that's one for Gia
number eight plant a private
ritual sorry sorry plan a private ritual
or invite friends to commit to one
action towards Earth
healing ooh like I
mentioned I mentioned the climate change
thing it's a big push and it is
connected with this doesn't it sound
like the same
thing I think it does number nine spend
a few moments meditating on connection
and the beautifully diverse Web of
Life of which you are an important part
Moon baby so now they're calling
you cuz Gaia is
known basically to have given birth to
the moon and then the moon it's it's
complicated I don't know the full story
but that's kind of what it is is that
you are the moon baby so all humans are
moon
babies 10 use art witchery to create
something beautiful from recycled or
naturally sourced materials to include
on your altar or share with the
community okay so this is
again
interesting actually I have to comment
on this because art is used a lot by
witches to and again art is not bad
God made art and imagery he used it when
he gave
Parables and so art isn't bad but it can
be used and is used in a lot of ways to
worship other gods or be used even um
Alistar Crawley's book on Magic also
tells you to use art in lots of ways to
invoke demons to be consumed if but
worship certain gods and goddesses so he
knows what's up they know what's
up so um let's continue
on 11 pick out an existing reusable cup
or purchase from a local artist and
bless it for good health and Earth
Wellness carry it with you to spread the
love and strengthen your stewardship
number 12 dye decorate embroider and
enchant reusable bags for abundance and
planetary Health make one for you and a
friend again we again we as Christians
or or if not
everybody mostly would agree that we
should be taking care of the Planet it's
a good thing reusing things or getting
rid of bad things are all good things
too number 13 plant or pot or plan if
the weather isn't ideal a native
planting as an offering to winged
friends pollinators or the genius
Loki okay so they're telling you
exactly what's you're offering this to
birds pollinators and the god
Loki so this was a like I said you can
see it right there this is by Molly
Roberts she is a witch that is teaching
you how to do this on her website down
below I didn't really want us to see her
altar but I wanted a little image to
show excuse me all of the things that
she has on her altar during this
time um those are all my sources let's
continue all right
the Feast of St
George this is the next one and this is
this gets a little hairy so just bear
with
me the Pagan and mythological
connections of St George's
Feast so the warrior imagery of St
George reflects Mars the Roman God of
War as well as pilia which is April SEC
22nd sorry
21st I can't read today after a lot of
working on the computer your eyes get
tired but it says pilia a feast festival
for pales or Palace that includes
livestock blessings and spring rights
Additionally the fairy Latina festival
for Jupiter involved protective rituals
for a prosperous season Horus Egyptian
god of protection and battle and Osiris
associated with seasonal renewal offer
symbolic parallels with themes of
safeguarding and the Earth's fertility
the god
Marduk oh sorry marduk's victory over
Tiamat representing chaos and nera's
guardianship over agriculture align with
St George's portrayal as a
protector figures like the Green Man and
jillo or hillo maybe agricultural I'm
sorry a Slavic God of spring and
fertility as well as fire purification
rights seen in festivals like pilia and
belan resemble the agricultural
blessings and the renewal themes found
in St George's day
Customs all right so let's talk about
what these rituals and practices
are in association H in association with
these gods and spring festivals they
were historically absorbed into the
Feast of St George through cultural
blending St George known as a war
Warrior figure and protector became
associated with themes of protection
seasonal renewal and fertility in ways
similar to the gods and practices of
local
cultures as a result many pre-christian
spring rituals honored figures like Mars
which is a warrior protector Palace
agricultural Guardian Horus Defender
against evil
and fertility figures like hillo and the
Green Man became interwoven with St
George's story over over time festivals
honoring St George often retained
elements such as bonfires livestock
blessings and symbolic battles with evil
okay
so listen to that because bonfires will
be important as we go forward um
symbolic battles as we heard about the
Royal shov Tide football we already saw
the themes of symbolic battles with evil
against each other in teams of two with
football
so back to what we were saying it's it's
highlighted right there symbolic battles
with evil as seen in the dragon and
slang Legend of St George aligning with
the protective renewal focused themes
celebrated in the
spring while the feast is named for St
George the practices reflect ancient
seasonal rights rebranded under his name
allowing communities to retain their
Traditions within a new cultural
context okay
interesting the Feast of St George is
also
known as the Blessed Virgin Mary
day all right so let's understand where
that connection comes from the
connection between excuse me the
connection between St George's feast and
its association with the Blessed Virgin
Mary or the Society of Jesus Jesuits
seems to stem primarily from layers of
traditional developed oh sorry tradition
developed within the Roman Catholic
context rather than from the biblical
origins or the life of St George himself
so they're basically like I don't know
where it came from it's just been tied
to this for some
reason all
right um second sentence there
historically the Roman Catholic church
has often adapted certain feast days and
associations to align with figures or
themes that were important to Catholic
tradition including veneration of Mary
the worship of Mary also called
marismas on that Jesuit so here's the
connection I'm just going to break it
down for
you the Jesuits in the Society of Jesus
worship Mary which is called
marianismo is as well
Catholicism then takes these Saints this
is where we jump to the the second
paragraph
there within the Roman Catholic
tradition certain saints were elevated
and celebrated with feast days but
paralleled Regional
customs and I'm going to stop right
there just a moment because I want you
guys to understand
this as I was saying the Society of
Jesus and the Catholic Church are
basically the
same um
and they worship Mary and the
Saints and all the gods and goddesses of
ancient times Babylonian caldan
basically the same thing Roman and Greek
so all the gods they can pack in there
to worship other
gods is what they do so just to get that
out of the
way um can't hear
anything what
they're talking about the oh okay good
never mind let's go back and let's
continue on to what I was saying about
the Feast of St
George
um okay St George was venerated as a
protector and Military figure this is
paragraph the second paragraph had his
feast day on April 23rd which aligns
with existing Springtime celebrations
and customs in some context his day
became associated with broader Maran
veneration themes so worship of Mary
especially as St George's imagery of
fighting a dragon or evil paralleled
Catholic views of Mary as a figure
overcoming evil so suddenly he is
merging with the worship of Mary as they
both seem
to mean or
foreshadow themselves as a figure of
overcoming
evil okay so the Society of Jesus
founded in the 16th century by Ignatius
of Lola placed strong emphasis on Maran
devotion as part of its spiritual
practices while the Jesuits didn't
originate St George's
Feast they integrated Maran devotion
into many aspects of Catholic life and
observance over time Mary entitled and
days of observance were layered into
various Saints feasts within Jesuit
influenced
regions wow isn't that
interesting
man okay last paragraph in some Catholic
regions April 23rd began to include both
the Feast of St George and Marian
devotions so then all of a sudden they
fully merged they overlapped each other
and it was known to be worship of Mary
instead of St George and they are one
and the
same this was a way to honor Mary
alongside popular Saints within Catholic
communities creating combined
observances with indirect connections to
St George's original
story thus the Blessed Virgin Mary day
for the Society of Jesus isn't at all
biblical but rather a result of
historical layering of Roman Catholic
Traditions over over
centuries okay
originally it stemmed from non-biblical
practices later merged with Mary and
devotion with the Roman Catholic
traditions we know that here's the
breakdown in many European countries
processions were common on St George's
day so this is how they worship or keep
the day the types of uh
activities and these often involved
Maran images or icons when I looked at
pictures of this by the way they had a
procession of holding the statue of Mary
on their shoulders while they walked it
through the
streets so yes that's definitely there
participants carried statues there you
go of Mary Andor St George through towns
to invoke protection so here they're
doing it to invoke something it's like
wearing a crystal on you to say that
you're going to be healthy and it it
it's going to keep you
healthy they actually walked these
statues through town to accomplish what
they would think to bring them
protection over communities and
agricultural lands
offerings of flowers and Greenery were
made to bless the crops and the local
environment traditionally this day was
used to bless Fields animals and
livestock in preparation for a fruitful
season the blessings which were adapted
into Catholic practices had roots in
earlier Springtime rituals dedicated to
fertility and the Earth so this is all
about worshiping fertility and the
Earth the invocation of Mary so calling
upon Mary to do these things was often
added as a way to bring her protective
influence over the land a blend of local
beliefs and marry and
veneration so just combine everything
why don't you the worship of the
fertility the Harvest the Earth and Mary
and the local beliefs at the time it's
just
crazy bonfires all right so this is the
second time we've seen bonfires in this
uh time of
season they were a common feature
especially in rural communities used
they are used to cleanse and purify the
land and to drive away eil Spirits or
lingering winter forces in some places
these bonfires became Maran vigils
oh which symbolized Mary's Purity and
light though they originally stemmed
from seasonal fire rituals so it's a
fire ritual for purification
made by the occult world and now is
being called the symbol of Mary as she
represents Purity and light how crazy is
this this is firsthand an example of how
they
overlapped and
twisted what they call Christian beliefs
into Pagan
ones all right the last point there is
that people often recited prayers
litanies and chants which in a Catholic
con
context invokes Mary's intercession for
protection okay protection health and
fertility these prayers were meant to be
spiritually protective and align with
Catholic teachings but in many cases
they only took on elements of
traditional folk magic this is Magic
when you invoke something or a god a
God's presence or protection in your
life this is none other than worshiping
another God not right not at all
okay so these are images of it in the
Freemason context with the G and square
Encompass on the um Flags there on the
left and then they kind of know what's
going on what they're doing and there's
kind of that hidden meaning for the
congregation on the the right this would
be a Catholic or um I guess yeah more
just Catholic congregation keeping this
day the cattle is the cattle are there
to be blessed
the food and first fruits quote unquote
are there to be
blessed in her honor I don't know it's
just this is yeah the hidden meaning
behind everything and how it would
look all right in areas where
folk pract local folk practices merged
with marry and devotion people would
often carry talismans okay if you don't
know what that is it is an object which
has been quote unquote blessed
with the presence of Mary into it herbs
or a God or power of a demon even or
whatever that's what talism are then
herbs or holy water blessed during St
George's day was used to protect their
homes and Fields this use of sacred
objects Bears resemblance to older Pagan
charms and protective spells which
became quote unquote
christianized through Maran associations
isn't it
lovely okay so in some regions the story
of St George slaying the dragon was an
was reenacted as a symbolic battle
between good and evil though this event
wasn't directly tied to Mary it became
associated with her role as a protector
against evil in
Catholicism oh how how weird while
formal spells were not part of official
Catholic
practices uh might think it always has
been actually by the way many local
Customs on St George's day included what
could be seen as Folk magic practices
charms and blessings for fertility as we
already heard they had herbs or plants
thought to promote fertility and
protection often blessed in Maran
rituals to christianize their use we
just heard that one witch lady saying
that she was going to take a plant and
bless it and put it on her altar to
remind her to treat the Earth well well
and to help heal it this would tie back
to
that okay while formal spells were not
part of official Catholic practices oh
we already read that sorry charms and
blessings here we have it house and
field cleansings also happened with
bonfires oo sprinkling of holy water and
the use of blessed herbs which were part
of cleansing rights meant to protect
households and Fields from
Misfortune practices that were remnants
of pre-christian meaning pagan
purification
rituals all
right wow there's a lot on this of
course I made this presentation but at
the same time it this is a big one this
is one that goes on quite a
while so not only does it have
everything to do with marry and
veneration or AKA
Catholicism within certain Traditions it
appears to trace back to ancient goddess
worship specifically linked to figures
like samiramis and the practices
surrounding Bale
worship samiramis a legendary ayrian
Queen was officially connected to the
worship of fertility Gods like tamuz and
was often depicted that was her son by
the way and was often depicted as a
Divine mother figure this mother and
child archetype prominent in many
ancient cultures became a recurring
theme again they know it this is
interesting they know that it's a
recurring theme which is is meaning that
they were just renamed different gods
names but were the same Gods over and
over again with a themean fertility
Cults across Mesopotamia Mesopotamia and
Egypt such as Isis and Horus and Ishtar
and
tamuz as the tra these Traditions were
integrated into religious practices
Marian imagery began to reflect titles
and attributes similar to these ancient
goddesses in particular the title Queen
of Heaven ding ding ding does anyone
realize that that came from Jeremiah
7:18 we aren't to worship the Queen of
Heaven she specifically mentioned in the
bible not to have anything to do
with anyway
continuing okay Queen of Heaven
associated with goddesses like Ishtar
and condemned in the Bible began to
appear in Marian
devotion this adaptation effectively
rebranded local goddess figures under
the Maran identity
okay now they're saying that the the
statues or images of the Goddess Ishtar
or
samis are suddenly
marry H then they Blended traditional
maternal and intercessory roles as we
know in Catholicism you're supposed to
pray to Mary to intercede for you
because she's the one who cares for you
not the father not Jesus she makes Jesus
aware of what you need help with
apparently
but we don't believe that if you if you
look at the Bible it is not at all that
role that she has
but they started blending this they
Blended all these pagan gods with Maran
identity of maternal um protection and
intercessory
roles culturally with culturally
familiar imagery of divine
mothers thus maryan veneration as it de
veloped Within These Traditions was
influenced by ancient fertility and
mother goddess archetypes the blending
of these roles nurturing interceding and
protecting in Marian worship aligns
closely with historical goddess worship
practices reflecting syncretism now
again I've talked about this before
syncretism needs to be known by most
people it means blending of all gods and
their worship together in
one you worship all these different gods
to get different things out of them to
bless you and protect you in different
ways and all of these gods are held as
an equal on all most playing levels of
worship or spiritual
things okay so they used reflected um
syncretism rather than Origins based on
biblical
teachings syncretism again is the
blending of different religious cultural
or philosophical beliefs and practices
into a unified
system often merging elements from
diverse
Traditions okay
so this is the image of
Mary um merged with an image of St
George slaying the dragon behind her in
his mythology his folk
tale as he is on a dressed as a knight
on a horse that's his story but this is
quite a cult in
esoteric sorry in esoteric and occult
contexts features like St George and
Mary could be adapted into symbolic
rituals blending protective and
nurturing archetypes with nature worship
this is how it comes full
circle then we have oh another
one A different one called St Mark's Eve
or
Mandi wow M
Thursday M Thursday observed in a week
leading up to Easter in the week leading
up to Easter traditionally commemorates
the Last Supper focusing on Jesus's
teachings about humility and service
over time certain Traditions layered
Mary and devotion again this is an
opportunity for them to do so into
Monday Thursday
observances often emphasizing Mary's
sorrow which was seen as alining with
the themes of sacrifice and compassion
the Jesuits known for emphasizing Mary
and devotion Incorporated the these
elements into their Holy Week
practices adding prayers and devotions
centered on Mary's
role in the passion
story
no
yeah some Scholars suggest that certain
Monday Thursday Customs particularly
washing rituals and feasting Echo
ancient spring rights of purification
and fertility which were present in bail
worship
oo wow another connection with bail
worship this is getting intense
fertility writes at this time of year
thank you often included washing or
anointing aimed at ensuring growth and
abundance mirroring aspects of Jesus's
foot washing adapted into Monday
Thursday rituals
these Echoes however are indirect and
reflect broader
Springtime themes rather than direct
influences in wikka so in witchcraft
spring writs similarly involve cleansing
and
renewal aligning with themes seen in
Monday Thursday while
wika as a formal practice developed in
the 20th century it Incorporated ancient
seasonal cycles and purification rituals
that are symbolically akin to themes of
Monday Thursday's renewal and
reflection interesting so this all
starts tying
together
okay in St Mark's on St Mark's Eve the
night before that day which is April 20
oh the day sorry the night before St
Mark day which is April 25th is marked
by superstitions and traditions such as
watching
rituals this was very interesting I've
never heard of such a thing but this
goes into many deep things it is where
people wait at churches or Crossroads to
see spirits or Omens of those who would
die in the coming
year as well as Divine their true
love I don't know how they connected a
true love kind of with dying but those
are the only two things that would tell
you who would die in the coming year and
who your true love would
be um Maran influences can be seen in
the addition of prayers for the deceased
oh wow okay this would connect with
why okay this is why Catholics light
those candles for Mary to hear you and
intercede on your behalf as you pray
your prayers to
Mary not true no it
doesn't hold any biblical or or true
connection
this anyway this is why they do
it um especially in Jesuit practices as
it says here where Mary was often
invoked again for protection and
intercession for souls okay so you can
understand how the Jesuit influences is
going straight into the Catholic church
and is held there it is commemorated it
is worshiped broadly
okay this syncr syncretic blending of
local customs with marry and prayer
rebranded ancient practices within the
Catholic context we know
that okay so let's go and read about
more of these watching
rituals some of the watching traditions
this is paragraph two on St Mark's Eve
recall ancestral worship and divination
practices similar to those in ba and
ancient near Eastern worship where
certain days were set
apart for contact with Spirits or
Omens these practices involved rituals
to honor ancestors or seek guidance
which were later adapted into
observations like St Mark's Eve within
the framework of Catholic
tradition in modern wiah again
witchcraft St Mark's Eve parallels
certain Veil thinning
rituals often observed around those
major seasonal points like Sam Sam ha
or uh however you say that which is
actually Halloween where participants
emerge in practices to communicate with
Spirits or honor the
dead though not directly linked St
Mark's Eve watching rituals resemble
these practices of seeking Omens or
messages from beyond beyond the grave
really Beyond in the spirit
world all right
which is wrong we shouldn't be
communicating with the dead or
worshiping ancestors or any of
that it also includes several Traditions
involving spellcasting and Herb
gathering for protection divination and
warding off
negativity especially within Wiccan and
folk
practices wiccans and neopagans may use
St Mark's Eve to gather potent herbs for
protective and div divinatory spells
such as Rosemary for protection Sage for
cleansing and mug wart for
insights all right so now they're trying
to use
herbs for spells and uh rituals and and
what is it characteristics which you
want to be part partaking in somehow
Sage for cleansing and mug wart for
insights these herbs are often
incorporated into charms or used in
rituals aimed at connecting with Spirits
or enhancing personal
protection traditional European
practices involve collecting specific
herbs so they still do this today in
Europe H and it was tradition of
that specific herbs like Yaro and
Hawthorne on this night to create
protective charms against evil or
Misfortune herbs are meant to be used
for good this is God's medicine but it
is not used the way that they say it
is they use it the wrong way to treat
people or for these
rituals so they would often hang them in
doorways these charms by the way that
they made or carried in small bags or
amulets believing them to be most
effective when gathered on St Mark's Eve
historically cunning folk such as
healers or spiritual practitioners there
you go there's the fake medicine
there would gather herbs on St Mark's
Eve and use them in blessings or
protective spells for their
communities these practices were aimed
at protecting homes ensuring health and
predicting fortunes drawing on the
symbolic power of the evening for added
potency in their
rituals these herb collecting and
spellcasting Customs emphasize
protection and connection with the
spiritual realm that's really all that
it's about continuing to today in
various folk and Wiccan
practices my goodness okay so here is
the proof here's different things that
they use Sage fern seed
nuts wow nuts
interesting um watching rituals usually
around a church peeping into the church
to see who goes
in meaning that they who doesn't enter
will supposedly be in the
grave or become bra Gravely ill but not
fatal seeing your own
wrath wow and and dying shortly
after and so on I just wanted to give
the proof for
that you can go back and read
that and here it is right in
a again a wicked
source and so with the Setting Sun of
the 24th we have St Mark's Eve they say
set aside as one of the tradition
traditional Knights for divining the
future this is specifically true for
matters the heart one of the most common
divination spells is as follows fast
from sunset on St Mark's Eve and during
the night bake a cake here we go a cake
again you might see a theme a huge theme
and I hope you recognize it by now again
samiramis Queen of Heaven all these
goddesses quite honestly that God Jesus
is warning us of in the
Bible they all had cakes again cakes
that were baked for these divination
rituals and to honor that
goddess so there's that that type of
trap a cake is great don't get me wrong
it might not be healthy for you but
there are healthy ones to make
um and but used in this way again is
wrong it is
wrong okay so let's go back to what I
was saying during the night they bake a
cake that contains an eggshell full of
salt
wheat meal and barley meal set the baked
cake to cool on the table and leave the
door to your house
open sometimes over the course of the
night your future love will come in and
turn the
cake certainly a spell like this
hearkens back to simpler times when we
were less in need of locking our doors
at night let alone leaving them open
personally this this Witch is writing
I'd go with the security of a locked
door and just wait to meet my future
love in a more public
place others Ed this the eve of St Mark
to foresee the shadows of all in the
village who would be buried in the
church yard in the coming year great fun
of course oh wow how is that fun this
requires some planning ahead however as
a spell needs three years to work three
years
goodness but they are dedicated I will
say that they wiccans in the occult
World know just like us we have to pray
to God and it's not always an immediate
answer it's he works things
supernaturally out into the natural
world that we live in and sometimes it
takes time years or whatever and we know
we have to be persistent they also know
this that
Satan works over time to do this as well
when they pray to him or whatever these
gods that are deceptively representing
him he starts putting things into motion
also of course he
can't do all things we know that and he
um is not as powerful or capable as God
God will always win and they will not
but I will say that Satan is real and
he does reward or give people what they
want especially when asking upon uh his
name as a counterfit of Christ he does
bless deeply in bad ways but it usually
comes with with a
huge obligation to him that if you do
not fulfill he will be putting you on a
uh what do they call it a a list for
assassination basically he will take you
out so just a note on
that um let's go back others use this oh
we already read that for each of three
St Mark's Eaves in a row you'll need to
fast and then spend spend the hours
between 11:00 p.m. and 1:00 a.m. sitting
on the porch of a church they say come
the third year in that witching hour so
they know what the witching hour is you
should see a pro procession passed
before you out of the Shadows of all who
will die in the coming year as the
excerpt as this excerpt from a poem by
James Montgomery suggest so all of a
sudden it goes back it Heralds back to a
time when they wrote a poem about this
ritual I didn't want to include it it's
I don't want to go into it and show
people how but all these things would be
used to do
this oh I did show it
there um poem is titled the vigil of St
Mark but back to matters of the heart
just as at Halloween so now they're
connecting the dots as I had mentioned
with Sam Hayne which is Halloween they
said this is a time for a long-standing
tradition of divination
so Halloween and St Mark dat is all
linked to divination rituals by using
let's go back to what it says down below
tradition of divination the last
paragraph there by nuts on St Mark's Eve
nuts you might think um yeah very
strange young women would set a row of
nuts on the hot Embers of the Hearth one
for each girl each would Breathe the
name of their intended into their Hearth
and if the love was to be true the nut
would jump away as it got hotter but if
the nut sat there and was consumed by
the fire the love was not meant to
be and they always have yeah poems and
things chants mantras to speak into
existence to manifest
it and it says the morning brings St
Mark's day with blessings upon the newly
sewn crops summer will soon be returning
in fact it's right around the corner
Again by traditional Reckoning of time
May Day is Drawing Near so they know
that Mayday is also and as we see that's
important to them as well we'll be
getting there with summer comes the
arrival of migratory birds in Northern
climates and birds are an important part
of the festivities of St Mark's
day cucko is that what that
says in particular and in England the
cuckoo is also known as St Mark's
gawk
wow the blessings upon the crops go back
to a much earlier celebration of late
April the ancient Roman Festival of robe
Galia celebrated to appease the mildew
spirits and to keep those newly swn
crops healthy and
thriving um yes I did say the witching
hour they did have that uh on the last
someone asked about
that and they did say that they they
would sit there and wait for the
witching hour to see what the uh waiting
ritual would show them who would die in
the next coming year but to continue
we have a new one h a very sad one I
would say um but let's continue here we
see
that on April
26th through May 1st which is May Day
May 1st is May Day
um we have what's called Grand climax
this is a pattern which you will see in
the occult
World they have it several times a year
and we'll be showing that but it's also
called the
demure which means unfortunately that
it's oral anal vaginal and the Corpus
debal so the corp corp of Corpus of Bale
you are killing
that uh you're going to be killing that
person after you do all that to
them and it has to be a 1 to 25y old
female so you got to arrange to choose
and this is what they do in the occult
World
on um during that
time okay so back to a little bit
lighter things we have wal
perano which is hexano or rude Mass
day on this day we have ST wbga which is
a prominent figure in early medieval
quote unquote Christian which means
Catholic history born around 710 ad and
Devon England she was of a notable
lineage within quote unquote Christian
circles or Catholicism belonging to a
family of high status that was
influential in spreading Catholicism in
Europe now just perk up a little
bit
uh this is going to draw a lot of
connections for everyone wanting to know
about the holidays and
also occult holidays and everything
these people have a lot to do with it
just a minute
before we
begin we're going to look at who her
father was her
father so St W
berga's father was St Richard the
pilgrim who was West Saxon Prince a West
Saxon Prince he was known for his devout
faith in his journey as a pilgrim to
Rome this early sorry this earned him
the status of Saint in his own right
within Catholic
Traditions reflecting the sanctity and
revered status of her family so as you
might know when you pilgrimage to Rome
and do all of the I don't know kissing
stairs or whatever rituals you are said
to
be uh brought up to the the rank of
Saint uh at least he might have done it
a certain amount of times that earned
him that title but that just shows you
how doing certain physical things
somehow that the Catholic Church says
will earn you sainthood but it's not
true so her brother which is St
willibald she has two brothers by the
way one is St willibald he was an
equally significant figure in the
Catholic church he became the bishop of
exot in Bavaria a highly influential
influential position and was
instrumental in founding monastic
community so he founded monasteries if
you will willibald was later canonized
as a Saint as well celebrated for his
missionary work and dedication to the
spread of Catholicism in Germany her
other brother St
Wald also held a significant role in the
church he became an Abbot and a
missionary in Germany eventually
founding the monastery at Heiden
Heidenheim where he served as Abbot he
was known for his role in establishing
the Catholic faith in what was then
Pagan territory and like his siblings
was later canonized as a
saint St bonface often regarded as the
Apostle of the Germans was actually her
uncle and one of the most important
figures in the christianization quote
unquote of Germany he was a close
adviser to the papacy and was
instrumental in organizing the church's
hierarchy in German lands is this
ringing a a bell this is kind of
like the world of Elites at that
time they were all in cahoots with the
papacy and would do anything he asked
them to do then they go and do all this
and they're devout to the Catholic
church and they all became Saints and
renowned people within the world and
Christian faith or Catholic faith and
there you go this is
like the the uh renowned Catholic but
occult world of the elites rising to
power for this time period and he was
yeah I already read that part I'm sorry
his missionary work last sentence earned
him high status within the
church and he became a central figure in
W berga's life providing her with
spiritual guidance and support in her
own missionary
work
okay so this family in itself
was always put like Heavenly and
supposedly the
best but while bur while
herself became an abbis so her brother
was one of the first or at least the
first renowned Abbott for herself she
became one of the most famous first
abuses overseeing the Dual Monastery of
Heidenheim where she led both monks and
nuns a rare and respected position in
her time her family's recognition in the
church greatly influenced her path and
her sanctification as a saint after her
death which was likely propelled by her
family's religious Legacy of course it's
from who you know how your family if
your family was famous and um popular
or kind of like Hollywood then you are
however her close association with
Wall's Bergen a night traditionally
marked by Pagan rituals has led many to
scrutinize her veneration and I would
say it for good
reason as the blending of C Catholic
rituals with mystical and Pagan Customs
is what you get here please listen up
this is why that matters whilst bergano
is clearly as you will see uh of pagan
origin and yet she is known on the same
day as that day she is the woman of
that's supposedly the the saint of that
day okay those are my sources on that
but examining her canonization we have
associations with W perono again which I
was going to mention oh the
contradictory symbolism surrounding her
Rebels sorry
reveals several non-coincidental
connections that showcase catholicism's
integration of pagan symbolism
especially as it relates to concept of
magic and mysticism perk up please
listen up this is going to get really
interesting right here number one
canonization and Pagan timing St wbga
was canonized centuries after her death
with her feast date set close to MayDay
aligning with ancient Pagan spiritual uh
spring rituals her Feast Day on May
first and the night preceding it which
is April 30th called wal perano was a
traditional night for Pagan festivities
aimed at warding off evil
spirits does this sound kind of
witchy this association with a night
marked by mystical traditions of B
bonfires chants and symbolic protections
against dark Forces aligns her story
with Pagan Customs rather than any
biblical
teachings very true and we're going to
see even deeper why number two her
contradictory role in warding off
witchcraft whil P um St wb's role in
warding off evil or being invoked
against witchcraft appears paradoxical
that's what she was known of that day
was supposedly you call on her you
invoke her spirit and it's supposed to
protect you from witchcraft however
while the church promoted her as a saint
with protective Powers invoking her name
against evil and Magic reflects a kind
of symbol
magic so it's almost as though they are
promoting and teaching you how to use
magic
yourself that parallels the very
practices it claims to
oppose I'd say so that's very
true this contradiction is
characteristic of Catholic
syncretism where figures from
pre-christian meaning Pagan or cultural
Traditions are repurposed for new roles
without fully shedding their original
mystical Association
we're going to go even deeper it's going
to be really cool hang in there number
three St walberg's appearance in
contemporary works like Harry Potter she
actually is represented and shows up in
Harry Potter did anyone know that please
tell me in the comments if you did where
she is depicted in relation to Wizarding
The Wizarding World and underscores her
connection to Mystical and Supernatural
themes her character serves as a
symbolic nod to her real world ass
associations with rituals and Pagan
Customs a subtle but clear
representation of her dual identity as a
saint associated with both warding off
spirits and Conjuring up Spirits o
interesting I got this from a an occult
Source by the way so that we kind of
know what's going on number four the
accounts of miraculous
oil flowing from St wura's relics are
steeped in Supernatural language
suggesting an influ influence Beyond
what's seen in typical biblical Miracles
yet is not right this miraculous
substance was believed to have healing
properties reinforcing her role as a
mystical
figure in ancient cultures the concept
of healing oils there you go mystical
liquids or sacred spring water was
widespread and that's why you have the
sprinkling do any any of this ring a
bell for people I have to laugh again
sprinkling of water
the ding I don't know what you want to
call it when they start sprinkling
things on you in the the church the
Catholic church was seen as it says
there and the catholic's adoption of
such imagery as St wsb's veneration
again mirrors these non-biblical
practices of
paganism these connections collectively
reflect how St wga's story was adapted
to fit a dual narrative the church
emphasizes her saintly power to protect
from evil yet her Origins and
associations tie very much back to the
very mystical and ritualistic practices
it says it s to distance itself
from highlighting the contradictory and
non-coincidental links between her
veneration and Pagan Customs again it's
going to get even deeper so this is why
it matters so much whilst perono or
hexano or rude Mast
day
um those familiar with St WS berga in
Harry Potter could definitely say she is
a witch because one would argue that she
is H very interesting so the Catholic
church is venerating a witch this
statement reflects her cultural
transformation into a symbol of mystical
and Supernatural associations further
underlying her ties to Witchcraft and
Magic her
popularization in Harry Potter as part
of the Wizarding World directly aligns
her with magic rather than solely
saintly qualities
linking her to the broader themes of
hexano which is called witch's
night celebrated on April
30th
okay so this portrayal is not
coincidental they
say St W berga's Feast Day aligns with
hexano completely on the same day a
knight historically associated with
rituals to protect against witchcraft
and she becomes part of a as she becomes
part as a of a dual narrative while
exstensively a saint means to ward off
evil her role in timing also makes her a
powerful figure connected to the very
practices the church claims to oppose
this is the second time they've said it
interesting it is very true in this
context her veneration and recognition
within popular culture especially
through media that openly celebrates
celebrates witchcraft further emphasizes
the integration of non-biblical
symbolism and blending of pagan
principle practices within Catholic
Traditions her Legacy therefore becomes
the one deeply intertwined with both
protective magic here we go she is known
for being part of protective magic and
Witchcraft underscoring the
contradictions of her being a venerated
saint of the Catholic
Church
okay let's see a little bit more what's
going on
St W berga's rise man that's hard to say
St W berga's rise to the position of
abbis was quite of a quite rare dual
Monastery a community housing both men
and women under her leadership is
particularly notable this is very rare
dual monasteries were uncommon
especially during the early medieval
period and required significant trust
and influence her appointment to lead
this kind of Monastery raises questions
about her connections yeah you would be
like well who do you
know and means by which she attained
such a
status suggesting that her role may have
been part of a larger strategy of
christianization that allowed
pre-christian such as Pagan and mystical
beliefs to persist into the cult the
Catholic
structures yeah one could say that no
kidding the establishment of these dual
monasteries allowed the church to to
merge distinct communities men and women
under one un saintly figures
authority too bad they didn't know if
she was a witch but while bur's
leadership would have required her to be
seen as deeply spiritual and influential
but her elevation was also likely
influenced by her alignment with
Traditions that included mystical or
protective Powers associated with L with
Saints by appointing her as the abis the
church may have strategically
capitalized here is the here's another
key point the Catholic Church always
puts these people into positions of
power to influence the world
culturally and she was used in this way
it says they capitalized on her
perceived connection to the mystical
world to sway Pagan
communities who might otherwise resist
Christianity what they call
Christianity this position of power
further reinforces the idea that her
role was not just a Pious
leader but a symbolic figure her
connection to the Knight of walls Bergen
a time steeped in ritual and protective
magic alongside her veneration implies
that her saintly
identity was intertwined with the
church's blending of local practices
into Catholic rights yes it suggests
that ws berga was not just a passive
recipient of sainthood but an emblem of
the church's approach to incorporating
influential figures with mystical ties
masking Pagan principles or practices
with Sanctified titles and presenting
them under the guise of Catholic
sainthood her prominence therefore
likely indicates she was part of an
inner circle here we go this I said
she's kind of like the inner circle of
the elite yes
okay the Inner Circle that aligned with
the church's acceptance of pagan
Traditions under the label of
christianization this dual role part
leader part figurehead for a ritualistic
Heritage would position her within a
framework that was neither purely
biblical nor exclusively quote unquote
Christian but but reflective of
catholicism's complex and often
contradictory Embrace of non-biblical
Customs as you will
see quite honestly as you'll see over
and over again in the Catholic
church so this is purely giving you the
facts to understand where all this comes
from excuse me comes from but it's hard
because it it's unpacking it and no
we're not against you know Catholics or
any other religion we want to give the
truth people to set them free of
worshiping other gods and being deceived
by Satan into doing these things or
being part of his deceptions and
trickery so let's continue this night
also known as hexano or witches night is
traditionally a time when witches here
we go it's going to fully show you what
used to be done on that night by the
witches and how it
overlaps a traditionally time when
witches were believed to gather for
rituals of magic often a top mountains
or secluded spaces again this so
interesting that this is all connected
they said Groves in the last I think the
last um holiday we were looking at and
now they have hillsides secluded spaces
and
mountaintops in European folklore this
not this night was seen as one of the
most powerful times for Supernatural
Gatherings H when witches would
convene excuse me it's a lot of
reading when witches would convene to
invoke Spirits cast spells and celebrate
rights of fertility and
renewal
goodness historically while Bergen
rituals included bonfires again the
bonfires man they were lit to ward off
evil spirits and these fires served a
dual purpose while outwardly meaning to
drive away D Darkness they were also
believed to amplify magical energy
providing which with a protective space
to conduct their ceremonies kind of like
when
they um
C draw a circle or cast their circle
around a pentagram or a fire before they
start doing the chanting and dancing and
all this stuff to call upon demons and
evil spirits
usually um so there you go the chants
and incantations incantations which is
were thought to chant spells or invoke
various deities or Spirits they
do but drawing on ancient Pagan
Traditions these incant incantations
would typically be focused on blessing
the land ensuring fertility for the
crops and strengthening their own
magical
powers okay potion brewing and Herb
gathering this was common for
practitioners to collect herbs specific
uh especially those associated with
protection or healing to brew their
potions or
tonics these rituals were believed to
imbue the herbs with heightened potency
during their mystical this mystical Le
night okay dancing in circles was
another essential element okay
symbolizing unity and protection
circular movement was thought to create
a boundary against negative energies
allowing practitioners to safely call
the spirits without in interference
sorry yeah this is
a hugely
sounding of course like witchcraft
because it is and yet she's associated
with this
weird so this is what it looks like most
of the time when they do this lots of
people gather and do this all together
so they would have offerings and
sacrifices offered symbolically to
appease local Spirits or Gods these
offerings would be food small trinkets
or symbolic items intended to invite
favor and protection these gatherings on
W perano are significant not just for
the symbol their symbolism but their
alignment with the themes of protection
and
fertility this is interesting when the
church placed St wga's Feast Day on May
1st aligning her with this night of
witch Gatherings it was clearly more
than a coincidence would anyone else
care to agree with that I
would the choice allowed the church to
subtly christianize the the night while
still recognizing and indirectly
preserving its pagan and magical
significance so they
almost preserved
it and lifted it up to
others the association of wall St walls
burga with a night known for Gatherings
of witches reflects catholicism's
tendency to absorb and reframe local
practices masking Pagan rituals with
saintly associations by transforming the
knight's meaning under walberg's saintly
protection the church could appear
toward evil even as it preserved a night
of deeply mystical and non-biblical
practices wow there's more rude mass now
some
might and I would ask why is this called
that all right it is a term historically
associated with the Feast of the
exaltation of the Holy
Cross oh boy which is celebrated on
September 14th in the Catholic Church
the word rude is an Old English term for
the cross or crucifix specifically
referring to the large crosses often
displayed in medieval churches Mass
refers to the celebration of the
Eucharist so rude Mass signifies a day
dedicated to venerating the Cross so
worshiping the cross that's what
venerating means by the
way on which Jesus was crucified they
say here's how rude Mass connects to St
wbga and wals Bergen interesting
number one symbolic cross imagery and
Pagan rituals the association of rude
Mass with the cross which is Central to
Catholic symbolism I hope that's no
surprise to people I know when I learned
this it was um and it can be a hard one
to swallow but as we're going to see yes
it's connected very much with these
Pagan things and the Catholic
symbolism is likely served to
christianize certain Pagan practices
just as rud Mass celebrates the power of
the Cross while bergano was adapting was
adapted into Christian sorry Catholic
tradition with st W burga invoked as a
saint who Wards off evil both rud mass
and W Bergen fall into the church's
pattern of reinterpreting pagan
festivities with Christian quote unquote
Christian meaning using powerful symbols
like the cross and Saints to replace
traditional Pagan icon
iconography so number two spring
festivals and protective rituals rude
mass is sometimes linked with Springtime
celebrations as crosses often floral or
green were used in agricultural rights
and rituals to bless crops and protect
them from harm this is similar to while
spanox function as a knight of
protection and purification intended to
ward off evil spirits and invoke
blessings for the coming
season the Catholic Church may have used
the symbol of the cross on root Mass to
overlap oh sorry overlay these
Springtime protections just as it did
with st wbga and WS
perono okay so there's that
connection whil
perano uh number three rud mass and
syncretism with W perano though
celebrated months apart rud mass and w
perono share roots in the syncretism
where Catholic symbolism becomes
intertwined with Pagan beliefs
about protection and fertility both days
serve as examples of how the church used
familiar symbols such as the cross for
rude mass and Saints for w perano to
reframe existing Customs creating a
hybrid tradition that retained Pagan
significance under a Christian
guise while rude Mass itself does not
directly relate to WS perono the
connection lies in the church's pattern
of overlaying Christian quote unquote
Christian which means Catholic Catholic
symbols on Pagan traditions
to encourage con conversion and
integration using figures like St wbga
or symbols like the cross to infuse
non-biblical practices with quote
unquote Catholic or Christian
significance yeah I don't know what else
to say about that so this is not that
you guys probably that's what it would
look like when the ult world is is
worshiping and doing this they have the
cross and someone hanging on it as well
and they have
yeah the pentagram and their Circle cast
and they're invoking all these demons
and protective rights and rituals and
then we have this kind of symbol which
is where you have basically the same
thing going on that's what I'm showing
there but it's claiming to
be Christ who died on the you know on
the cross for you whether quite quite
honestly the cross was used as a
basically a charm a a Talis man for for
these occult people and the Witchcraft
world
to
um as they were saying maybe I can go
back as they were saying it was
used actually to almost invoke the
demons as that's how I would reframe
it um but this is way the Catholic
Church a supposed holy Congregation of
people come together and do the same
thing just the way that the occultt
world would but say that it's because of
a different reason a spiritual
reason um which is
false so here we go we're going to
actually explain it a little
deeper the cross symbol predates
Christianity whether this is real
Christianity or fake Christianity which
is
Catholicism it has associations with
various ancient deities including tamuz
a figure in ancient Mesopotamian
religion in Babylonian and Samarian
mythology tamuz was a god of fertility
vegetation and renewal celebrated in
Spring wrs that symbolize death and
rebirth the cross symbol particularly in
its t-shape or tow cross as we know it
to be is linked to tamuz and was used as
a symbol of life and renewal in
pre-christian meaning Pagan
cultures this use of the Cross as a
symbol of Life Death and rebirth
parallels many aspects of Catholic
symbolism even though is not rooted in
biblical Christianity when the Catholic
church incorporated the cross into its
iconography it adopted a symbol already
Laden with layers of meaning from Pagan
Traditions just as tamu's cross
represented renewal and the cycle of
life and death the cross in CA in
Catholicism became a symbol of
resurrection and Redemption this was not
a New Concept but rather it echoed
ancient rights that celebrated cyclical
renewal and divine
sacrifice how does that connect with
while BGA and W
Bergen
well they use this symbol in witchcraft
as well both W burenok and the cross
reflect how the Church Catholic Church
rebranded ancient symbols and practices
under a Catholic context while spok a
night with deep Pagan Roots involved
rituals of fertility protection and
purification and was linked by St wbga
and her Feast
Day similarly the cross originally
linked to Tamu and fertility Rights was
adopted as a central symbol Within in
Catholicism despite its non-biblical
Origins non-biblical meaning that it was
definitely Jesus did die on a cross for
us and that is powerful
but I'll just give my input here usually
when you wear a cross you think it's a
Christian symbol but why do the rappers
do it well this is exactly why they wear
it as a a pagan symbol quite honestly to
invoke their gods their demons and so on
and it was actually used as I know it
from all my research and I've said this
in a different episode it was used
against Christ when he was put on it to
actually try to make him subservient to
that God tamuz that's why it was in a te
that's why it represented tamuz but he
would not be subservient to it he rose
again and tamuz is supposed to be a god
of
renewal and rebirth but Jesus showed
himself to be Lord of that and the only
God who can actually do that that's why
it matters to us but that doesn't mean
we should be having
at least in my personal opinion that
doesn't mean we should be using the
cross or wearing it
or uh memorializing it that
much um
because it actually isn't a good thing
you you usually do see it around
people's necks who are very atheist and
very occult and that that that's why
because they know exactly what it stands
for and it's not a Christian
thing
so um let's continue on
all right they Sanctified Pagan elements
such as the cross associate we already
know
that um the connection of St wbga to W
perano and her role as protector against
witchcraft mirrors the reworking of
pagan symbols to appear as Catholic
Traditions while retaining their
original
Essence and purpose in
Disguise both the cross of tamuz and the
rights associated with w perano involv
themes of renewal protection and life
cycles which the church mirrored in its
Narrative of the Cross as a symbol of
Christ's Resurrection in St wb's role
and warding off evil so they just keep
telling you it's Jesus it's about Jesus
and and Christ's Resurrection but it's
not it's it's really about all the Pagan
stuff behind it that they are still
worshiping that's why they're attached
to this why that's why they still do it
these elements are not coincidental but
are rooted in long-standing patterns of
incorporating symbols familiar to pagans
into a Catholic framework effectively
blending ancient non-biblical practices
with the Catholic ritual these blending
this blending illustrates a strategic
syncretism where the Catholic Church
adopted and adapts symbols like the
cross rooted in tamu's worship and
whilst perano practi practices
repurposing them to fit a Catholic
narrative while maintaining a connection
to their original meanings effectively
bridging Pagan beliefs with
Catholicism
okay that that's done now May 1st known
as belain in the wiccan World which is
actually called walberg's
Feast so may
day it unfortunately is linked with the
oult world above in that uh chart of
Satanic ritual abuse known as the Druid
fire festival and coven
initiations that's what they do on that
day and the belan festival originated
from the ancient celc Traditions is
known as a fire Festival that marks the
beginning of May and celebrates
fertility growth and the renewed
Vitality of spring so the same you see
the same pattern and themes within all
of this that we're talking about
really um but it is typically celebrated
belan is on April 30th into May 1st it's
one of the key so there you go they
actually put those together with W
Bergen o and May 1 as a very key
important two days that you worship is
one of the key festivals in the the
wheel of the Year observing ancient by
ancient Druids and modern pagans alike
the festival is rooted in fire rituals
and symbolic actions meant to honor the
life-giving forces of nature protect
livestock and crops and initiate
individuals into spiritual paths it
transformation into Mayday highlights
the church's syncretic approach to
adapting again Pagan Traditions into a
benign
cultural or spiritual day that really
had no kind of origin like that fire
rituals at its core belain was a fire
ritual a fire festival with large
bonfires symbolizing the sun's
lifegiving energy participants would
light those fires to purify and protect
both people and animals livestock were
often driven between two belain
fires as a protective ritual believing
to guard them from disease and bless
them with fertility and health for the
coming year I like to pause right there
this is important because as God talks
about this whole do not have your
children pass through the fire here
they're not just passing people through
this fire they would you know do other
rituals like we're going to see but you
burn the fire to supposedly have good
luck or good um growing in the next year
but they would actually pass animals
through the fire to do
this do like do you see how like obvious
that starts standing out in your brain
the Bible was talking exactly about this
that this is bail worship the very kind
that they are warning us
against not to have anything pass
through the fire as a ritual to the gods
or to Satan really or baale like why why
can't we see this and realize
it I hope now that I brought it to your
attention that it it makes sense and
that you'll realize it from now on let's
continue so at its core it was a fire
Festival protecting both people and
animals they were driven through it okay
fertility and renewal celebrations
belain marked the beginning of the
planting season and its rituals focused
on the fertility of the land animals and
people traditionally celebrants would
engage in dances often weaving ribbons
around a maple here you go Mapes and yet
again please go and listen to my other
presentations on who is the Rainman and
androgyny and so on because I break down
what the mapole is
and it says right here a phallic symbol
representing fertility to invoke
blessings of abundance that's where they
would rise up to worship Ishtar or
Easter and they would take those Maple
ribbons and and do the whole thing but
that they would do that right when the
sun came up at dawn as ishar is the
goddess of the Dawn and so is myamis and
these other
gods oester and
and they are all the same but they when
they were goddesses the dawn you would
have the Sun come onto you at the Dawn
and this would begin a maple orgy
basically okay and that was supposed to
invoke blessings of
abundance couples would also participate
in hand fasting ceremonies this is very
oul which they bind their hands together
as a form of trial marriage for a year
and a
day
okay this is what it looks like in the
Pagan oul World they still keep this a
lot in the European um areas they will
just have this openly at like a park or
whatever and people are dressed like it
kind of like a ren renaissance fair and
they will uh invite all passer buyers
and and strangers to
participate of course they don't do
usually unless they have tens and stuff
I'm sure you can find crazy places where
the orgies will still happen but um
that's not usually in the public eye
they will usually just have you
participate in the minor mapole ribbons
and stuff that signifies um and
symbolizes a lot of this Pagan
junk
okay so May 1st belan walls burgo Feast
this would be coven initiations and
spiritual connections it was also a
traditional time for initiations into
covens or Druid
orders okay that should tell you a lot
during this Festival initiates would
undergo symbolic rights of Passage to
align themselves with the rhythms of
nature in the mystical world for Druids
this festival marked a profound
connection to their gods and
spirits and belain became a time to
deepen one spiritual bond and solidify
commitment to the spiritual
path how it became Mayday let's talk
about this as Catholicism spread through
Europe the church adopted many elements
of belan and rebranded it as mayday
here's how number one Maple dancing and
floral symbols this maple dance was
rooted in ancient belan Customs but it
was retained as a central feature of
Mayday dancers would bind ribbons around
the pole representing the weaving
together of masculine and female
energies this tradition though not
though now
secular retained the Pagan themes of
fertility and unity a reflection of
belain symbolism number two May queens
and green men so here you are you're
actually dressed up
like basically the Queen of Heaven and
you're rebranded and crowned a May
Queen um symbolizing the goddess of
spring and fertility and then there's
men who are becoming and dress like
green men the the God we talked about
representing Nature's rebirth these
figures definitely hearken back to
ancient deities associated with belan
and were retained as quote unquote
christianized Mayday Celebrations by the
Catholic Church
this is also again from an occult Temple
of the old religion circle of the Sacred
Grove in which they talk about what you
do with Maple here is one of our coven
here is the one of our coven which it
follows the maple is a phallic symbol it
is inserted into a hole in Mother Earth
okay so here's where the sexual part of
things not only a act that they carry
out but it also is what they say that
mother earth goes through every
year they do this to represent the act
of the goddess and God making love so
they can conceive the divine
child as men and women weave around the
maple the flower
wreath at the top slowly it comes down
once it hits the ground conception is at
hand so that's what they say the weaving
of the ribbons happen all the way down
to the ground until conception
happens but let's look deeper into the
meaning of the M Poole they
say I wasn't really going to that was
enough for me I wasn't going to look any
deeper I knew it was going to get
dirty so it says during belain coven
initiation rituals were traditionally
carried out to align new members with
the energies of the Season symbolizing
rebirth renewal and
commitment here's an overview of how
that would look usually purification by
fire and water does this hearken back at
all to people who are in Hinduism they
do purification by water rituals all the
time they have to do this every day
to be
um oh shoot a brah I think a Brahman
um and so here you have other cultures
we I mean sorry religions that we can
truly look at and go okay this is
actually bail worship as well fire is
Central in belan symbolizing
purification and transformation
initiates would often pass between two
bonfires a practice dating back to
ancient Celtic Customs believed to
cleanse them of impurities and negative
energies in in some traditions initiates
may also be lightly sprinkled or
Anointed with water okay again does this
sound like the Catholic
Church yes symbolizing their rebirth
into the coven and connection with
Nature's
elements okay so I just have to think
about this I need to talk to you guys
for a minute so you have this sprinkling
and you have passing through the
fire which is baale worship Bale is
known Nim you know Nimrod started bail
worshiping his child
tamuz you
know when people on Ash Wednesday get
that cross painted on their
forehead guess what that stands
for this is getting me excited I'm sorry
I'm getting like nervous it's tamuz it
signifies you are initiate it even says
that initiate of
tamuz because of the the to cross that
is being painted on your head with ashes
so just a little connection there it's
kind of
interesting all
right
so all right sacred Oaths and binding
rituals new initiates would take sacred
Oaths of loyalty to the Covenant and its
members these Oaths often include a
promise to honor the coven's code of
secrecy okay does anyone think this
sounds like
Freemasonry secrecy actually that's
that's all of cabalism the occult World
gnosticism paganism
Freemasonry uh the wiccan world did I
say cabalism already whatever yes it's
all of it they even have this I hate to
say this I hate to say this but in uh
Judaism when they have the cabala cabala
which is integral to Judaism they have
several
um codes of secrecy that you have to
keep they have to uphold its values and
commit to spiritual growth as well in
the wiccan or druidic Traditions
initiates sometimes wear cords or abound
or are bound symbolically with ribbons
to signify their bond I hate to say that
that sounds like Judaism as well or
cabalism the red cord around your or um
bracelet around your hand representing a
commitment to the coven and the sacred
path nature communication sorry
communion and grounding ceremonies are
also involved coven initiations often
involve connect connecting deeply with
the natural world especially in outdoor
settings initiates May participate in a
grounding ritual okay so here's where
grounding comes in where they connect
physically and spiritually with the
Earth such as by placing their hands or
feet on the ground or embracing trees so
tree hugging
is I guess more or less involved in the
themes we've been seeing in worshiping
Mother Earth or teram Mater and green
you know all the Earth basically Mother
Earth the gods that represent a mother
who gave birth to the
Earth um these practices are meant to
align them with Nature's energies and
prepare them for responsibilities of
their spiritual
journey now one note on that just
because they use grounding doesn't mean
grounding like getting your shoe off
your foot and actually walking in grass
and stuff isn't good for you we should
break away from a lot of the cultural
binding in shoes all the time so
grounding can be helpful and it actually
does seem to um there's a chemical in
dirt I did a whole paper on this that
actually is therapeutic to your body
when you have contact with the skin with
that chemical in the dirt you actually
get somewhat of a release of endorphins
that help you heal from things so
grounding can be helpful I'm not sure
I'd call it grounding but just go and
walk walk in a natural setting
barefooted and it'll actually help your
health
okay anointing and naming ceremonies
initiates would receive
anointment with oils or herbs believed
to have protective and purifying
properties such as frankincense or myrrh
okay so here's where they Unfortunately
they are um the counterfeit of what
Jesus is and what he was given
this is often done in combination with
the giving of a craft name or spiritual
name which represents their new identity
within the coven they usually have two
different names like they're saying one
name for the public world to know you by
and one for your coven fellows I guess
or whatever you call them this name is
typically chosen based on
characteristics or symbols meaningful to
the initiate and reflects their inner
nature or aspirations kind of like
what's your spiritual animal
or whatever number five Circle casting
an elemental invocation many covens
perform an elemental invocation where
the four elements earth air Fire and
Water excuse me are called upon to
bless to bless and empower the
initiate
battery in initi in a Sacred Circle
coven members May stand in each
Direction Northeast South and West O
Okay does this sound like like the the
elders that were seen in the temple
turning towards the east and so on and
worshiping other gods it
should to represent the elements
invoking their powers to offer
protection guidance and strength to a
new
member symbolic death and rebirth a
powerful aspect of initiation is the
symbolic death and rebirth where the
initiate dies to their previous life and
is reborn into the spiritual
path this can involve rituals such as
kneeling blindfolding okay here's like
kind of like The Hazing thing or leading
the initiate through a labyrinth or
darkened path to emerge into light this
rebirth represents their new role and
identity within the
coven Blessing by the high priest or
Priestess in many covens the initiation
is led by high priest or Priestess who
offers blessings and words of guidance
they may place a ritual item such as a
an a them a ritual oh a cere ceremonial
knife like you may have seen Anton L
actually has a video on this and how the
the knife is ceremonial and symbolic and
all this stuff it really isn't very good
a wand or chalice upon the initiate
symbolizing the transference of wisdom
protection and the empowerment of the
coven's
lineage celebration and feasts also
following the initiation A celebratory
Feast often takes place symbolizing the
unity and shared journey of the coven
Foods associated with belain like Honey
Cakes there you go with the cake fruits
and wine are shared as an offering to
the Earth and as a symbol of abundance
and
fellowship now here's interesting thing
these initiation rights underscore the
significance supposedly of belain as a
time of renewed spiritual connection
both for the individual and the coven
the rituals are designated not only to
welcome new members but also to align
them with the coven spiritual beliefs
and practices
deeply rooted in the energies of Nature
and the symb symbolism of life's
Cycles the connection between belain
being called Joseph the Worker this may
blow your mind it's totally
crazy so it is actually called another
name for belain which is the wiccan
Sabbath or Sabbath for
them is also called Joseph the Worker it
lies in the Catholic Church's rebranding
of May 1st to honor St Joseph
the patron saint of workers this
adaptation was likely an attempt to
align with the significance of Mayday a
day traditionally celebrating Spring's
renewal and fertility in belane
rights by dedicating May 1st to St
Joseph in 1955 the church sought to
provide an alternative to both belaine
Pagan celebrations and the intern
International labor movements observance
of Mayday so here's where labor
movements such as
Labor Day came
in this shift symbolically redirected
the focus from seasonal infertility
rights to honoring hard work and
humility contrasting Bain's celebration
of life cycles and Catholic ideals of
Labor and
dedication okay I hope you guys are
eating this up it's a lot I know and um
we're just going to plug through it
because we we have to still continue we
have a lot to go go through still so
please bear with me all right CCO de
Mayo May 5th has Pagan Roots closely
tied the celebration of belan an ancient
Celtic Festival that we just spoke about
belane is traditionally celebrated on
May 1st but in some regions and
traditions festivities extended into the
first week of May making May 5th a
continuation of the themes associated
with belan here's how it
connects belain celebrated around 1 is
the Celtic Festival we saw that it's a
fire Festival honoring life growth and
the energy of the sun oh here's where
the sun comes in they were just truthful
in there they slipped a little nugget of
Truth in there it actually celebrates
the energy of the sun
interesting with Traditions that include
dancing around a mapole lighting
bonfires and decorating with flowers by
May 5th belain celebrations would often
still be
ongoing especially in regions where the
festival was celebrated over several
days this was a time to bless crops and
livestock for fertility ensuring a
fruitful growing season the seasonal and
agricultural fertility festivals of May
early May indeed existed long before CCO
Deo and is associated with the Mexican
oh and is sorry existed long before CCO
DEA was actually associated with Mexican
victory over the
French that's the reason that they give
us that's the reason that they give us
today for actually having CCO demo that
the Mexicans got Victory from the French
but in fact it is not true from what I'm
finding out it is exactly this they're
they're worshiping belan as well so keep
that in
mind pre-colombian civilizations like
the Aztecs and Mayans had their own
Springtime and early summer celebrations
rooted in the cycles of nature as well
Agriculture and the rain gods T linked
timed to a sign with planting seasons
and in the return of
rain Aztec festivals the Aztecs had a
ritual cycle in early May dedicated
to tock tock the god of rain and CH Chu
chaku goddess of rivers and Waters
asking for rain to ensure fesal crops
and a Bountiful Harvest so now they're
even telling you what gods they're
worshiping um that are actually the same
again the counterfeits of nimrod and
samiramis and Ishtar and everything
again Mayan celebrations similarly the
Mayans honored chak the rain God in Fes
festivals to bring on the rains that
would support rain like crops like maze
Central to their survival these
indigenous spring festivals involved
rituals dances offerings and prayers so
the same kind of
thing they embody the deeper ancient
connection to the land and Seasons that
predated the arrival of the Spanish and
the eventual rise of Cinco Deo so while
May 5th became a historical
commemoration over time the Pagan roots
of honoring nature and deities in early
May are actually part of an older
Heritage that predates the colonial and
nationalistic layers that later were
associated with the date even in gaic
cultures the first few days of May are
dedicated to belan observances and
serving served as a significant
transition between
Seasons the timing of it overlapping
with May 5th holds special relevance for
gaylik people as it is considered a
powerful time for protection protection
rituals here we go protection magic
protection rituals where fires were lit
to safeguard against evil spirits and to
bless homes people and
livestock so we come to May 14th
Mother's
Day okay just a
moment lots of water for the
throat so the origins of Mother's day
unfortunately as you can see from the
first sentence it is also traced back to
Pagan festivals before it was actually
made oh Pagan festivals by the way
celebrating mother deities and the
concept of mother earth once again
ancient cultures around the world held
festivals honoring motherhood and The
Feminine La lifegiving forces of nature
here are the few key examples in ancient
Greece they had the Festival of Ria
where they celebrated Ria the mother of
gods and goddesses of fertility and
motherhood with Springtime
festivals all
right they also had powerful gods
associated with her like Zeus Hera and
Poseidon these celebrations focused on
gratitude of fertility creation and
growth ancient Rome also had for
Festival of cbel which was called
Hilaria to honor cbel known as the great
mother or Magnum moer during the Spring
Equinox in the late March cbal was a
mother goddess associated with fertility
nature and abundance
so here's where it overlaps so we have
Rio we have Cel we have mothering Sunday
which I'm sure perhaps you haven't heard
of in Celtic and British traditions in
Britain mothering Sunday emerged from
the Middle Ages as a day where people
returned to their mother Church the
Catholic Church they had grown up in in
their area and reunited reunited with
family while it was later adapted into a
Christian observance it retains elements
of honoring and nurturing mother concept
connected to both church and
family number four the Earth Mother
celebrations or sorry Mother Earth
celebrations of course we talked about
Mother
Earth and also early Pagan celebrations
of motherhood whether it was through the
goddesses the Earth or other feminine
deities it emphasized themes of renewal
nurturing and sacred cycle of
life it has definitely influenced
traditions of modern Mother's Day
observances transforming ancient
reverence for Mother Earth and fertility
into into a day to honor human mothers
while still echoing the original theme
of gratitude for nurturing and
life okay so this is a woman who was
actually given um credibility for
basically creating Mother's Day into
what it is today her name is Anna Jarvis
and she wanted to honor her mother and
all mothers in some instances which were
taken which takes us back to ancestor
worship really practices like visiting
grave sites laying flowers wearing white
carnations were
especially used by her for deceased
mothers reflecting elements of ancestor
veneration over time idealizing mothers
and honoring their memories annually
introduced a reverential r ritualistic
tone that resembled ancestor worship as
the holiday spread globally it sometimes
merged with existing customs of honoring
the dead further edting these practices
and elevating the remembrance of mothers
Beyond Simple tribute
all
right we come
to May
24th this is called on May 24th is
called Our Lady of the
way
it is said to
have both Christian meaning Catholic
Catholic spread of quote unquote
christianism Christian I mean and um
pre-christian or Pagan
Traditions also rooted in Maran devotion
which would draw on motives from Pagan
mother goddess figures as well and local
deity worship that
preceded Catholicism this title
especially in its origins in Europe may
have connections to older goddess
Traditions that represented guidance
protection and the journey of Life a
common thing theme in Pagan religions
where goddesses such as Isis and Egypt
beliefs and emis or Diana and Greco
Roman Traditions were seen as protectors
or Travelers and oh Protectors of
Travelers and paths in ancient Pagan
Rome the concept of a protective figure
for travelers and roads were
familiar as Travelers would often have
offerings make offerings to deities of
safe
passage these deities became blended
into Catholic iconography and devotion
especially when Rome adapted Catholic
elements that resonated with its
previous
beliefs interesting effectively
sanctifying previous Pagan Concepts
under a Catholic guise okay once again
they're they're the best at
this this was not uncommon of course in
the Catholic
Church the title Our Lady of the way may
therefore be seen as a part of the
syncretism preserving the essence of a
Divine female protector for those on a
journey an idea readily familiar to
pagans while placing it within a Maran
framed as Mary Mother of Jesus context
this reflects how the church's
historical integrated the church
historically integrated Pagan elements
to spread Catholic teachings across
regions familiar with these
motives incorporating and reinterpreting
them into its doctrines and
practices so this is kind of how we're
going to see how they keep it while
Catholics have this day our lady of the
wayy day it is less observe universally
observed outside of the Jesuit
Community Maran devotions are common
throughout the month of
May Catholics familiar with this title
of May May honor her by recognizing her
guidance and protective role especially
for those on journeys of or missions we
just saw that this observance is deeply
rooted in the Jesuit tradition with our
lady of the way symbolizing Mary's
intercessory role for those traveling
physically or
spiritually the feast that they have
serves as a time of renewal for Jesuits
often marked by prayer mass and personal
reflection on their missions and
calling so our lady of the way which is
also
Madonna interesting that Mary's statue
is usually also Madonna is associated
with May 24th as a day of of observance
particularly among Jesuits this title
for Mary originated in Rome and holds
special significance within the Jesuit
Community as their patroness the image
of Our Lady of the way historically
inspired St Ignatius of
lyola okay that should mean that uh I
hope you know that that name you should
know that name the founder of the Jesuit
order who dedicated the original Jesuit
mother Church to her which is called IL
Jesu in Rome the Jesuits May 24th is
observed as a day to honor our lady of
the way by recognizing Mary as a guiding
figure for those on their spiritual
Journeys Jesuits particularly venerate
her on this day reflecting on her role
as a protector and intercessor
especially for those involved in
missionary work and spiritual Direction
all right so the theme goes on and on
the feast day often includes a special
mass celebrating in her honor with
Jesuits Gathering to reaffirm their
dedication to Mary as their guide so
here they're even reaffirming that they
believe that she is their
their way that is they're going to guide
them on their path for Christianity or
Catholicism prayers hymns and readings
focus on Mary's protection and guidance
with an emphasis on her role as a comp
companion on the spiritual path in some
Jesuit communities the feast may include
processions featuring the image of her
symbolizing her role in guiding and
accompanying those on the Journey of
Faith so they have devotional acts such
as lighting candles so here we go
lighting candles also can be used as a
bellain thing
and communal prayer sessions also honor
her on this
day Memorial Day I hate to say this I
actually thought it might be pure and
benign but I was wrong Memorial Day in
the United States
observes is observed on the last Monday
in May is recognized as a day to honor
and remember military personnel who
served uh died in service however such
some argue that its Origins as well as
its timing May often faint have faint
Echoes of older Pagan and esoteric
traditions of honoring the dead that go
beyond military
remembrance so this is how it does
number one Festival feasts honoring the
dead which were common in ancient Roman
traditions in late May the Romans held a
lamura a festival for appeasing Restless
Spirits this was the time to honor the
deceased and perform rituals to protect
the living from
malevolent Spirits although lamura
wasn't a military commemoration it
focused on keeping peace with the dead a
concept that resonates with the spirit
of Memorial Day many ancient societies
held spring festivals to honor and
communicate with the dead or celebrate
the cycle of life it's possible that
selecting late May for Memorial Day
indirectly resonates with these
traditions of seasonal venance
sorry uh reverence for the deceased
although it is not officially recognized
as a continuation of these Customs it is
always the last day of May to to overlap
with this ancient Festival that is key I
hope that makes sense that should be
pretty clear and
legitimate um those are the sources for
May Memorial Day and Flag Day again I
thought that might be
um a day that didn't have any pagan
origins but I was
wrong it connects with ancient totem
poles which were used such as a flag to
honor groups or Clans honoring totems
this helped them have supposedly a unity
and identity and protection for the
community Flags serve a similar purpose
in our modern
times um Freemasons also have some
symbolism um influencing the flag they
have long held symbols and rituals that
honor certain colors geometric shapes
and Banners some speculate that the
celebration of Flag Day with with its
emphasis on colors and symbolism May
reflect Freemason
ideals of unity and allegiance to a
collective identity although there's no
direct link to the founding of Flag Day
many early American leaders and Military
Figures were Freemasons and the values
and unity and respect for National
symbolism align with Masonic principles
in summary while Flag Day as it is
celebrated today doesn't have clear
pagan origins its timing near the summer
solstice and its themes of honoring
symbols of unity and strength Echo
ancient festivals and traditions that
revered communal symbols the ideal sorry
the idea of the flag is a totem of
national identity and the June
celebration found towards the end of
June which is the witch Sabbath Lithia
which will come soon we'll see that
aligns with light and power reflecting a
continuation of deeply rooted cultural
practices repurposing it in a modern
patri patriotic
context okay so they're just one one
side they're showing how the totem pole
was used and how we kind of do the same
thing with the
flag okay Father's
Day all of a sudden we've jumped and
that's okay um June this is June 16th
obviously and Father's Day is always
celebrated on the third Sunday in June
and I hope that you realize this as well
a lot of
these key major
holidays are
actually mostly
Sundays why because they want to
venerate or worship sun and Sunday is
for the Sun and Sundays are the days
they're going to usually choose for
holidays to kind of
double venerate not just the gods but
the Sun as well it has roots so Father's
Day has roots that can be Loosely
connected to ancient Pagan festivals
honoring father figures male deities and
the cycle of life
though it began in early in the early
20th century as a complimentary holiday
to Mother's Day ancient culturals
cultures held festivals and observances
with themes similar to honoring fathers
and patriarchal figures so this hearkens
back to ancient Rome and the parentalia
festivals celebrated in February which
are dedicated to honoring ancestors
including fathers and forefathers so
this goes back down the lineage down
Generations like you're honoring all of
them that are dead and
gone this nday Festival so nine days
involved family gatherings rituals and
offerings to the deceased especially
male ancestors to keep their memory
alive although not specifically tied to
the June date of modern Father's Day
parentalia emphasizes respect for
paternal inage and family
Legacy oh this also has connections with
sun worship and the masculine Divine
June's summer solstice has long been a
period of celebration in various Pagan
traditions marking the peak of the sun's
strength so that's what they say in the
oul is that it marks the peak of the
sun's strength in June in many ancient
cultures the sun was associated with
masculine energy power and
protection for example a connection with
the Norse god balder a sun god is
associated with beauty and strength
around the
solstice similarly the Kelts celebrated
lug I think I'm saying that right a god
of light skills and leadership in summer
though his primary Festival which is lug
nasad was in August these deities as
paternal symbols paternal symbols
represented traits such as leadership
guidance and protection resonating with
the ideals often celebrated on Father's
Day oh here's more ancient Greek and
Roman fathers of the Gods so the Greeks
and Romans revered father figures in
mythology a lot especially as uh with
Zeus Greek and Jupiter the Roman version
who were seen as the fathers of Gods and
Men while there was no specific Father's
Day for the gods their roles as
patriarchal figures in myth mythological
ah in mythology symbolized Authority
protection and guidance festivals
honoring Zeus and Jupiter often took
place during the important times of the
year with rituals emphasizing their
paternal and protective roles over
Humanity for the Greek Zeus was
celebrated with the Olympic Olympia
festivals every four years which means
Olympics which emphasized his role as a
father figure to gods and humans
alike got to help this parched
throat okay in ancient uh Egyptian we
have Osiris as a father
figure he was considered the father of
pharaohs and the embodiment of Life
Death and rebirth Al those main
festivals take take place in the fall
Osiris was reserved as a patriarchal
figure who taught Agriculture and
civilization symbolizing the fatherly
qualities of wisdom and
continuity number five totem PS again
and ancestor worship many ancient and
indigenous cultures practiced ancient
worship venerating familial ancestors
and patriarchal lineage as a way of
connecting to its past and honoring
family roles this reverence for paternal
ancestors can be seen as an early form
of honoring father figures though it was
not limited to a specific
day okay
wow if this is not um quite a lot now
we're going to cover
juneth which happens June 19th jun's
themes of resilience Heritage and
Liberation can Echo the values
associated with certain African and
Egyptian deities that embody strength
guidance and freedom in Yuba tradition
oan God of iron war and labor represents
strength and resilience qualities
celebrated in the spirit of juneth
obatala a god of wisdom and peace
reflects Justice and Clarity aligning
with the themes of emancipation and
progress in Egyptian mythology Osiris
god of the afterlife and rebirth
symbolizes the cycle of life and
Liberation from past struggles mirroring
the celebration of freedom on juneth all
the Roman festivals of the Goddess
libertas though not directly tied to the
date May bear resemblance to Lithia
which happens a few days later and was
kept a little later in regions around
the world these deities represent
qualities that resonate with the
holidays honoring of endurance Heritage
and Collective Strength certain African
and Egyptian deities also
align symbolically with the Lithia the
summer Solage celebration in June which
honors the peak of the sun's power and
themes of abundance renewal and vitality
in Egyptian tradition raw the Egyptian
sun god is particularly connected to the
lithia's celebration of light and life
at its peak raw symbolizes creation
power and the sun's life-giving Force
reflecting lithia's themes of abundance
and renewal Osiris associated with
cycles of life and rebirth resonates
with lithia's focus on growth and the
fullness of Life symbolizing a turning
point in the year's seasonal cycle in
Yuba tradition oan and obat obatala also
connect to the themes of strength and
wisdom that Lithia celebrates ogun's
resilience and association with Earth
and later Echo the midsummer focus on
Nature's Peak and vitality while
obatala's wisdom aligns with reflective
balanced energy often celebrated during
Solstice
rights many African cultures Celebrate
life cycles renewal and Community
abundance Concepts Central to Lithia
through ancestor veneration and
celebration of unity
and oh Unity with the
land drumming dancing and feasting are
common in these cultures reflecting the
same Community spirit and honoring of
life and abundance that Lithia embodies
while these deities and ancestral
practices aren't directly celebrated
during Lithia they share symbolic
resonance with midsummer's themes of
light growth and connection to life
cycles aligning naturally with the
spirit of this H pagan
holiday so this is kind of what it would
look like if you combine all of what's
coming at you from the pagan origins of
juneth a very much a lot of Egyptian
stuff going on there and the African
culture types of
gods okay now we get to Lithia the very
um one they were talking about Lithia is
also known as Midsummer it is an ancient
Pagan celebration associated with the
summer solstice which Falls around June
21st in the northern hemisphere this day
marks the longest day and shortest night
of the year celebrating the peak of
sunlight
warmth and the abundance of
nature its Origins are rooted in various
pre-christian Traditions across Europe
particularly among the Celtic Germanic
and Slavic
peoples Celtic and Germanic tribes will
saw the solstice at least as a powerful
time when the when the nature sorry
natural and Supernatural Realms were
closely intertwined it was a period for
celebrating the life-giving power of the
sun which reach which reached its Zenith
a prominent Legend of its period
involves the oak King and Holly King a
symbolic battle that represents the
changing seasons and cycle of life and
light and dark the oak King who rules
over the waxing year of of Ule or Lithia
sorry Ule to
Lithia embodies growth strength and the
flourishing of nature at Midsummer he
gives way to the Holly King symbolizing
the gradual decline of daylight as the
year waines towards winter
unfortunately uh Lithia is another
Wiccan Sabbath or major
holiday
um in which they celebrate the summer
solstice and they have
again um well it's a little bit
different but origies and they have a
human sacrifice or animal sacrifice
where they have to have oral anal and
vaginal sex with it and this can happen
with any age male or female or animal
they're very specific about
unfortunately the age or type of victim
they need for all of these things and so
um even that has importance
unfortunately so this is what it looks
like uh what would look like when they
celebrate Lithia lots
of fire and and wheels of the year and
dancing and so
on it connects deeply with druidism as
you might have guessed druidism means um
the ones who know the oak actually I
think in druidic Traditions the oak tree
was a sacred symbol of endurance wisdom
and connection to the Divine the oak
King represents the force of Life growth
and sunlight deeply revered in druidic
practice as a powerful figure tied to
the Natural order and the cycles of the
Year Druids who were known as the
spiritual leaders of the ancient Kelts
would hold ceremonies in Oak Groves and
saw the oak tree as Central to the
connection with the Divine okay the oak
King therefore is more than a
mythological figure he embodies the
druidic reverence for the natural world
particularly the son's lifegiving Force
making the solstice an important point
of balance and transition in Slavic F
folklore Midsummer was linked to kopala
night a festival of fire water and
fertility this celebration included
rights to honor the Sun and promote
growth fertility and love rituals would
include bonfires again representing the
strength of the Sun in its at its height
people would gather around these fires
dance and sometimes jump over the flame
as a symbol of purification protection
and good luck flower crowns and Greenery
they would Adorn themselves with flower
crowns garlands and Greenery as a
tradition that stems from honoring the
fertility of the earth flowers herbs and
plants gathered at Lithia were believed
to especially be potent with protective
or healing
qualities common plants associated with
Lithia include St John's wart
elderflower mug wart and ver
vain okay dancing and music they would
dance and have music often lasting
through the night to honor the tuning of
the Year turning sorry the Turning of
the Year drums flutes and other
traditional instruments set the Rhythm
for dances around
bonfires divination and Magic Lithia is
a powerful time for divination and
Performing spells especially those
related to love abundance and protection
pagans believe that the veil between the
worlds is thinner at this time like they
do at H Halloween and belan enhancing
one's ability to connect with Spirits or
receive
guidance they also honor deities of the
Sun and fertility they use this Knight
to invoke or honor gods and goddesses
associated with the sun light and
fertility these could also include
balanus a Celtic sun god Helios the
Greek god of the sun and amasu a
Japanese Sun Goddess depending on
individual or Regional practices so
there you go they actually explain it's
all the same pretty much but each each
culture has a different name for that
sun god feasting and Community
Gatherings feasting on seasonal fruits
vegetables honey and Mead which
is beer basically was customary as this
was a celebration of the year's Bounty
or sorry Earth's Bounty families and
communities gathered to share in the
abundance of the season the overarching
theme of Lithia is balance and trans
transition while it celebrates the peak
of light and abundance it also marks the
moment after which day days begin to
shorten leading eventually toward
Harvest and winter this day holds a
sense of Duality honoring the height of
the sun while recognizing the slow
return of darkness in summary lithia's
pagan origins are rooted in honoring the
Earth the Sun and the cycles of life
with festivities centered on fire
fertility music and Nature's Bounty for
Druids the oak King is an embod sorry an
emblem of sacred growth and divine
presence reinforcing lithia's symbolis
symbolism of life
at its fullest this observance is a time
of Celebration and gratitude marking a
high point in the natural cycle of
growth and
light I hope you guys are learning a lot
um and hanging in there I know this is a
lot but it's worth it these are most of
the holidays that um the occult world
doesn't want you to know about and
really don't doesn't think you'll take
the time to learn about because it
actually starts connecting the dots for
you to put together the picture of what
they're doing over and over again and
what God's they're really
worshiping okay we have June 24th St
John the Baptist
day St John the Baptist day is
celebrated on June 24th and his
connections to pagan origins especially
including Jesuits and Freemasons for
reasons that intersect with Catholic and
Pagan
Traditions St John the Baptist day is
closely aligned with the summer solstice
June 21st also known as Lithia or
midsummer period was significant in many
Pagan European Traditions that
celebrated the height of Sun's power
with fire festivals bonfires and rituals
that honored the sun fertility and the
abundance of nature so it's kind of the
same thing it was widely um celebrated
among the Kelts Slavs and Germanic
peoples as Catholicism under the guise
of Christianity spread throughout Europe
the church often adapted Pagan festivals
to Christian yeah we already know that
days to ease the conversion process they
say by placing the Feast of St John the
Baptist on June 24th the church provided
a Christian quote unquote context for
the existing Midsummer celebrations
transforming into a time of pagan Sun
worship celebrated as a Christian figure
who heralded the coming of Christ the
themes of light renewal and the Triumph
of Life Central to Midsummer are easily
integrated into the Christian Narrative
of St John the Baptist as the Forerunner
of Jesus
the Jesuits as part of the Catholic
Church hold St John the Baptist in high
esteem due to his role as the
Forerunner of Jes of Jesus and his
embodiment of spiritual Purity and
dedication the Society of Jesus or
Jesuits value the the supposed virtues
of humility service and spiritual Zeal
that John the Baptist represents so
here's where we need to perk up and
listen up because they have a huge thing
for John the Baptist and they kind of um
I don't know if it's true but they
represent him poorly they also claim to
be come somewhat followers of
him
and you'll just see how they flip it on
its head and they kind of use those
lessons
improperly his feast day being so close
to the summer solstice also symbolized
the decease of the old sorry decrease of
the old Covenant and the preparation for
the new mirroring the Jesuit mission of
spiritual renewal and transformation so
basically do away with God's
covenant the which we might understand
is The Ten
Commandments um and
Freemason uh Freemasons have a deep
reverence for St John the Baptist
considering him one of their patron
saints there you go symbolism of light
and Enlightenment associated with
Midsummer and St John the Baptist
resonates with Masonic values of seeking
knowledge and spiritual
illumination the Masonic connection to
St John's day likely has roots in evil
stonemason guilds which celebrated the
solstices and were dedicated to Saints
who represented moral integrity and
spiritual wisdom The Duality and balance
Freemasons emphasize the balance between
light and dark known and unknown in St
John the Baptist day of Midsummer
represents the height of light before
the gradual Return Of
Darkness
okay where was I okay this Duality
reflects the Masonic journey of moving
from ignorance to
Enlightenment festivals and lodges
Masonic lodges often hold special events
or in
installations on or near St John the
Baptist day aligning with their
celebration of moral and spiritual
growth so they twist it completely
turning it upside
down and not using it
properly they also use bonfires and
light on this day
um this theme of light is Central to
both what they call the Catholic
interpretations of St John as the herald
of Christ and the light of the world and
to Masonic ideals of Enlightenment water
and baptism is used it's linked to the
element of water through baptism in
Pagan Traditions water was
often venerated or worshiped during
Midsummer so there's an interesting
connection okay June 29th the Feast of
St Peter and Paul um the Feast of St
Peter and Paul on June 29th holds
particular significance for Catholics
Jesuits and Freemasons due to its themes
of unity strength evangelism and
Spiritual Authority which resonate with
the values of mission and missions of
each group here's how they connect for
Catholics the foundations of the church
have this understanding that St Peter is
regarded as the first pope okay and The
Rock upon which Jesus Built the church
his role as a foundational figure speaks
directly to the Catholic understanding
of apostolic secession
uh succession and chur Church Authority
St Paul on the other hand represents
missionary Zeal the spread of
Christianity even to the point of
militaristic force to persecute the
people of God who get in the
way did you hear
that so Paul who was an assassin
basically of the
Christians I need to talk to you about
this yeah Paul who became oh I guess he
was Saul and he became
to stop killing God's people because
they had the True Religion now they're
taking these themes the Catholics are
and realizing they're turning it back on
its head they're like he was a great
example of how we are supposed to take
our faith so far that we are going to
actually treat people the same way with
militaristic Force if we have
to together Peter and Paul Paul embody
the church so we have the first
pope quote
unquote and you have the example of Paul
being someone who kills God's
people but they are um embody the
church's dual mission of upholding the
faith and evangelizing the world
essential pillars of Catholic identity
they
say all right themes of strength and
dedication celebrating the Marty
martyrdom
of Peter and Paul reaffirms values like
resilience and loyalty to Faith even in
adversity sometimes you have to know
when to stop and when you're in the
wrong and that's not what Paul had he
when he became Paul and came to Christ
he finally realized but that's not what
the church the Catholic Church here is
um upholding they're actually saying
we'll be resilient in the face of
anything and everything even if we're in
the
wrong despite adversity because we
believe we're right just we know we're
right
and they say their sacrifices under
Roman persecution are remembered as
examples of unwavered Faith unwavering
faith and commitment which serve as a
reminder of cath to Catholics of the
virtues of courage and
sacrifice so it corresponds with Lithia
and light symbolism because it was near
Lithia symbolizing the light at its peak
the Catholics had the overlap of
Christ's light throughout through the
apostles and the church they say the
Catholic tradition honors the spiritual
light by celebrating the ancestors who
brought Enlightenment to the world
through their faith for the Jesuits
encompasses evangelism and education
they took this on um as a Catholic order
knowing for their emphasis on education
and missionary work to find inspiration
in St Paul's tireless evangelism and
adapt adaptability in spreading the
gospel across
cultures they mean a different thing
they mean exactly what they're saying
and seeing you're seeing right here with
they would take cultures
and paganism and make it quote unquote a
Christian thing that's not what Paul did
but they believe it to be that in his
tireless evangelism which means even
using Force if you have to Paul's
mission to the Gentiles mirrors the
Jesuit goal they say of reaching new
audiences with the faith in fostering
intellectual and spiritual
growth okay so this also is dedicated to
spiritual Authority in the service which
Jesuits value as St Peter's
steadfastness and Authority viewing him
as a model of
leadership oh St Peter by the way if I
didn't mention that grounding it in
humility and service Peter's symbolic
keys to Heaven resonate with this Jesuit
commitment to keeping Souls sorry
helping Souls find their way spiritually
and providing guidance through spiritual
exercises and education this is actually
key this is a big deal because they
became known Jesuits are the ones who
started schools the
and they
also yeah they started spiritual
exercises and education and making it a
um mainstream thing that
had basically the things that the world
wants to push on to
you and indoctrinate you with so
sacrifice for greater good they say the
the Jesuit motto is for the greater
glory of God which aligns with the
sacrifices of Peter and Paul they say
who devoted their lives to God's service
the feast underscores the importance of
total dedication to Faith a central
tenant of Jesuit life for Freemasons
Duality and symbolic balance is key
Freemasonry values Duality and balance
you don't want to be du dual you don't
want to have Duality you you want to be
one thing for God he
says that you need to have your yes B
yes and your no be no that means
basically be you and
be true to who he calls you to be
anyway they are said to embody this
Peter as the rock of the faith
stabilizing and Paul as the missionary
Spirit which is transformation this
Duality represents two complimentary
pillars of Enlightenment or Paths of
Enlightenment the search for inner
stability and the outward journey of
growth aligning with Masonic and ideals
of balance between action and reflection
they also have the symbols of keys and
gates with St Peter of course they say
he has the keys to Heaven a powerful
symbol of access to Spirit ual knowledge
and divine Mysteries Freemasons who use
these symbols to represent the pursuit
of Enlightenment see the keys as a
metaphor for wisdom and a quest for
understanding the mysteries of life and
the universe community and Brotherhood
Freemasons have a communal aspect of the
feast Gatherings processions and shared
meals which mirrors freemasonry's
emphasis on fraternity and unity
Freemasons may see the feast as a
reflection of the principles of mutual
support shared purpose and Brotherhood
that are integral to Masonic lodges
they also share bonfires and lights the
tradition of bonfires for St Peter and
Paul's Feast are inherited from the
midsummer celebrations of course where
would where else would they come
from which aligns with the concept of
Enlightenment Catholics Jesuits and
Freemasons alike can interpret the
symbol symbolism of fire as a spiritual
illumination resilience and Purity the
overlap with Lithia is no coincidence
however nor is it that they say as it is
that Catholic the Catholic holiday
represents
and respected by these groups because of
Peter being the supposed first pope and
Paul being the example of zeal enough to
kill and cleanse and purify in the name
of the order so that's what they took it
as those are their examples the Jesuit
oath has been viewed as an expression of
absolute loyalty the pope and the
Readiness to undertake significant
sacrifices or actions to uphold the
church's Mission using Force if
necessary that you can see that in their
thing they it's very graic actually and
they actually vow to do this on a global
scale this interpretation aligns with
the symbolic Legend Legacy of Peter and
Paul in two distinct
ways okay they say which is really weird
this is really interesting for those who
you know believe in kind of the New
World Order and the governance of the
world Paul actually was said to
represent foundational Authority and
governance of the world symbolizing the
churches the Catholic Church structural
power and the centralized leadership
role of the Pope this is where they say
partly that they have the power to do so
to control the
world that they have um rights to be
that role the leadership role in the
world Paul they say represents the
Evangelical Mission sometimes fervent to
the point of zealous action even against
opposition his dramatic transformation
from persecutor to promoter of
Christianity quot quote is seen as a
commitment to the purity of Faith
regardless of the obstacles or
opposition encountered in historical and
critical readings this commitment to
Doctrine has occasionally been framed as
a mandate to confront or cleanse any
ideologies or groups considered harmless
or harmful sorry to the church's Vision
while these perspectives are debated
they Echo the intense loyalty and
dedication to a higher cause that
certain interpretations of the Jesuit
Mission have embraced in this sense the
Feast of St Peter and Paul commemorating
these Saints legacies of loyalty and
sacrifice May reinforce the Jesuit ideal
of unwavered sorry unwavering commitment
to their mission even when it invites
opposition or involves opposition to
those seen as hindering their vision for
the
faith oh dear there we
go so now we come to
July July 1
is known as um only in the occult world
as demon
Revels the demons Revel day it's a blood
sacrifice that's needed it's a druid
sexual association with demons that they
um carry out on a female of any
age uh then we go to
July
4th which is Independence Day it has um
connection with ancient Roman f a public
Festival um honoring the gods and the
state these festivals included rest
feasting and patriotic displays to
reinforce unity and celebrate the
state's strength although not directly
related to the Declaration of
Independence this tradition of gathering
in early July to honor communal identity
parallels the American custom of
celebrating Freedom unity and State
pride on the 4th of July it also symbols
of light and fire as we know from
fireworks um
these also have roots in ancient Customs
where light and fire are symbolic of
energy protection and celebration in
various cultures fire was used as a tool
to signify Triumph and to ward off
negative energies particularly during
times of
public celebration similarly on July 4th
fireworks serve as a powerful symbol of
freedom and national pride visually
embodying themes of strength and
resilience this also has to do with
Freemasonry as many found fathers of the
United States including George
Washington and Benjamin Franklin were
Freemasons Freemasonry which draws on a
variety of ancient and myth mystical
Traditions emphasizes symbols like light
knowledge and freedom Central to the
Fourth of July celebrations the pursuit
of Enlightenment and Independence aligns
with Masonic values as well of personal
and societal Freedom resonating with the
ideals commemorated on this day the
themes of freedom and rebirth are there
also with their rights from pagan
world the Patriotic rights and communal
Gatherings are also there um with fourth
of ju July parades also echoing from
Pagan
festivals picnics and public Gatherings
this practice of communal celebration
honoring shared values and identity
resonates with Traditions that sought to
reinforce cultural bonds through shared
festivities and expressions of loyalty
so they want
you um through this they want to make
you bonded to this the state and have a
sense of loyalty to them that they will
actually be there for you or you have
some Brotherhood or
something Unity is what they want to
accomplish unity in this feeling and in
Gatherings and
celebrations um
okay so what the Bible says about this I
just thought this was um
fitting it says no no one serves as a
soldier serving as a soldier in 2
Timothy 2:4 entangles gets entangled in
civilian Affairs but rather tries to
please his commanding
officer this is to mean that the
commanding officer is understood to
represent Christ or God whom Believers
are called to serve wholeheartedly
civilian Affairs symbolizes distractions
or concerns of the world that might pull
a Believer away from their Comm
commitment to God this verse calls for
believers to prioritize their
relationship with God
above other commitments or Earthly
entanglements including National or
social allegiances the idea is that just
as soldiers duty is to follow orders and
focus on the mission given by their
Superior a Christian's mission is to
please God not to be distracted by
secular matters that could weaken their
focus on spiritual growth in light of
discussions about rich national pride or
other Earthly affiliations this verse
reinforces the idea that a believer's
ultimate loyalty should be to God rather
than any worldly
entity it encourages single-minded
devotion underscoring that our highest
duty is to please God by living in a
life aligned with his teachings and
purpose rather than becoming overly
invested in temporary worldly identities
or
Pursuits this is another reason why we
have this channel we're trying
to Showcase and show you how many things
in our society are actually deceptions
and distractions from Satan and they're
saying saying that
um even this national pride and
and celebration is actually distraction
many things are
actually but that's what it's
saying
okay July 25th is St James Day St James
day traditionally celebrated on this day
is recognized in Catholicism to honor St
James the Apostle one of Jesus's 12
disciples however like many Catholic
observances elements of this day can be
linked to pagan origins and are still
made they were assimilated into its
celebration especially in areas of Spain
and Celtic regions also the day
memorialized for being the unveiling so
this is really key I hope you're
listening oh please listen this is the
same day July 25th St James day is also
the same day known for the unveiling of
the bamit statue in the satanic
Church okay I hope that's ringing a
bell Pagan Connections in the Iberian
Peninsula or Spain and Portugal pre
Catholic pilgrimage routes the region of
galatia in Spain where St James is said
to be buried was historically home to
Celtic and Pagan pilgrimage practices
long before Catholic influence so
they're not original
what a surprise ancient people made
pilgrimages to this area particularly to
finest finestra maybe literally the end
of the Earth as part of sun Worship in
the honor of the solar deities solar
worship and spirit or summer rituals in
Pagan Traditions July marked a time for
honoring Sun gods and engaging in rights
to celebrate the peak of Summer
pilgrimage route that later became the
Camino D Santiago was already
spiritually significant as it symbolized
a journey toward the the westernmost
point in Europe where people believed
that they could encounter the gods of
the setting
sun when Catholicism spread through
Spain early Catholic leaders saw the
benefit of aligning St James with these
established pilgrimage practices
transforming their Sun worship journey
into a Catholic pilgrimage in honor of
St James
suddenly okay in Celtic influence it
also celebrates um lug NAD or Lamas in
early August it actually
um has festivals that are common a
festival this is lugada laas is a
festival marking the beginning of the
harvest season St James's day aligns
closely with this period leading some to
believe that elements of lug nasad
celebrations were absorbed into Sams St
James
festivities symbolism of the Sacred it
should be sacred I should have said that
the scallop shell the scallop shell
commonly associated with St James and
the Camino D Camino de
Santiago has roots in in Pagan symbolism
or pre- Catholic symbolism that's true
too in ancient Celtic and Roman
Traditions the shell represented
fertility protection and divine presence
the shell which Travelers began to carry
actually as a symbol of their Journey
may have originally TR represented the
Pagan Journey towards Enlightenment or
favor for the gods the adoption of the
scalp's shell and certain Midsummer
practices aligned with St James day with
the Region's pre-existing Celtic
Traditions allowing for easier
transition or converts from paganism to
Catholicism
okay um the path for pilgrimage becoming
a part of St James the Camino was part
of a network of pagan pilgrimages where
Travelers sought spiritual encounters
often tied to the cycles of the Sun and
agricultural festivals the pilgrimages
also were connected to the stars and the
Milky Way this Cino Santiago or Way of
St James as it was called is often
associated with the Milky Way which
ancient Europeans saw as a path leading
to the afterlife or a Divine or to the
Divine Realms the pre Catholic pilgrims
traveled West following the Milky Way in
pursuit of spiritual renewal a tradition
later absorbed into the Catholic
framework as a part of honoring St St
James the Camino's alignment with the
Milky Way and its deep connection to the
Stars reflects ancient European
spirituality and predates Catholicism
symbolizing a spiritual journey that was
then recontextualized to fit Catholic
narratives around St
James okay so this is what it would look
like they just replaced the Pagan
deities to be St
James they called him the figure of
protection and Patron of of Travelers
and pilgrims
and a role that many Pagan deities often
filled he was a martyr and Warrior
symbol in Spain St James has become
known as Santiago
Matamoros St James the Moore Slayer a m
a militarized figure often depicted on
Horseback helping to drive out perceived
enemies of the faith this image of St
James resembles pre Catholic Warrior
deities and heroes who were believed to
fight on behalf of their people blending
Pagan ideas of protection protective
Gods with
Catholic hagiography
or um kind of like
hieroglyphics the veneration of St James
as a powerful protector likely absorbed
aspects of pre- Catholic Warrior deities
allowing a smoother transition for
converts again the early Catholic Church
strategy of syncretism there you go they
just outed themselves allowed these
elements to be redefined within a
Catholic context giving rise to
Traditions that contain continue to
carry traces of their Pagan
past all right July 27th is a grand
climax this happens a couple times a
year but um it's really
again really disgusting where they have
a human
sacrifice um child or adult female this
time and it's also oral anal vaginal and
Human Sacrifice or deore which is
killing
it it holds significance in a cult and
mythological circles viewed as as a time
for heightened spiritual activity and
ritualistic energy the grand climax
ritual observed in certain oul
Traditions is associated with rituals
meant to invoke Supernatural energies
often involved involving offerings or
symbolic acts to connect with dark or
spiritual forces it also has a
connection with astrological
significance it is aligned or has the
influence of Leo they say ruled by the
sun Late July is believed to be a
powerful period for channelings personal
strength and transformation sometimes
fueled by Mars Mars's assertive
energy serious rising in the dog days
late July aligns with the helal rising
of Sirius the dog star linked to
heightened Supernatural power and
renewal the Dog Days connecting to
sirius are seen as a time of spiritual
ual transitions in increased
intensity okay in many Traditions they
recognize Late July with fire and light
rituals once again symbolizing
transformation and power themed TI
themes tied to Leo's fiery
influence this period is often
Associated also with intense spiritual
energies believed to enhance one's
ability to cross sorry to access other
worldly powers or protect against darker
forces these themes make July 27th a key
date in oult Traditions blending
Celestial mythological and ritualistic
elements into the time a time of
symbolic Climax and Powerful spiritual
activity in ult Traditions this is
usually in satanic or esoteric calendars
they have four main Grand climax dates
throughout the
year again this is a time of heightened
spiritual energy in which they take I
guess
they um they fully take paron one is in
bolock in bulk February 1st through the
um this is actually what we know as
Easter I'm sorry that's not right
um actually I think that is in bulk
which is Easter W perono which is
belan the summer climax which we're
talking about July July 27th is
Midsummer and Sam hanne which is
actually October 31st or Halloween are
these time period in which the grand
climaxes happen these dates correspond
to seasonal cycles and align with Pagan
or cult Traditions that view certain
times of year is spiritually charged
each Grand climax is chosen to maximize
ritual impact of tapping into natural
and Celestial energies associated with
these seasonal
Transitions okay the grand climax in
occult Traditions happens several times
a
year because Within These
systems there are multiple designated
high energy periods believed to align
with cycles of nature celestial events
and changes in spiritual energy here are
reasons why so number one seasonal and
Celestial Cycles where it follows
natural and cycles of solstices
equinoxes and moon phases which are
thought to influence spiritual energy as
well they're often seen as periods of
portals or times when the e the veil
between Realms is thinner making it
easier to connect with Supernatural
forces so this is actually how they
usually explain that they believe the
veil of knowledge and understanding in
mystery is thinner during these times to
take on more Supernatural forces within
you and understand and commune with the
demons and
spirits okay so alignment with Pagan
festivals as well they often mirror a
lot of the belaine Sam Haan and other
fire or harvest
festivals and have the climax lunar
phases and ritual power they go along
with lunar
phases esoteric and astrological beliefs
in energy Peaks some occult beliefs hold
that specific times throughout the year
height carry heightened cosmic
energy aligning rituals with these Peaks
is thought to amplify the effect of the
ritual using natural energy energy to
achieve desired outcomes in summary the
grand climax dates which happen several
times a year allows for alignment with
various natural Celestial and
astrological energies believed to
enhance ritual significance mirroring
ancient and Pagan Traditions that
observe similar seasonal and Cosmic
patterns so can someone say
astrology okay so unfortunately this is
kind of what it would look
like um in ancient Rome Mars the God of
War was honored at various points of the
year it has connections with this as
well with certain rituals involving
sacrifices to call on Mars for strength
and
protection the association association
of Mars with heat intensity and battle
energy can resonate with the late June
sorry July's Grand climax in oul
practices aligning with themes of
conflict power and
protection so we're jumping again one
more holiday in July July 31st is
ignacious lyola day so why not worship
the day like the guy who actually made
the Jesuit
order he is in fact the one who did this
while this day is primarily recognized
within Catholicism some connections to
Pagan occult and mythological themes can
be
inferred we're going to see about
this Jesuit symbolism um the IHS
actually is is this Jesuit Order symbol
IHS is a f they say it's the first
letters of Jesus name in Greek but is
often set with a radiant Sunburst the
Sunburst symbolizes associations with
solar deities in various Pagan regions
as the sun was widely venerated in
ancient civilizations such as raw and
Helios sun and fire Ignatius himself
emphasized the concept of Illumination
and spiritual fire aligning with the
theme of inner
Enlightenment a concept also prominant
in many uh mystery religions and
esoteric practices the sun symbol in
imagery may suggest parallels to Sun
worship seen in other faiths as
well um this is kind of what that looks
like and in mystical and spiritual
exercises he was the one who made this
up by the way so if you find spiritual
exercises a set of meditation and
contemplative practices these exercises
share similarities with my mystical
practices and other Traditions which
focus on achieving Altered States Of
Consciousness aligning with certain
esoteric or ult traditions where
meditation is used to reach higher
awareness or Divine connection we can
say that we see this in um in schools
where our kids are being kind of
forced to meditate and have
contemplative practices or unified
um what is it
Consciousness and
so there's just a lot um he's known he's
actually the one who made uh Sports in
schools and actually made it a regulated
thing to particip in sports
and and so on um so he's known for
bringing in these my myth mythical and
spiritual exercises and he actually made
a lot of the
colleges
today like Yale and you Harvard and a
lot of those
ones so alleged secret rituals some
critics and conspiracy theorists suggest
that the Jesuit order engages in rituals
or practices that are cult in nature
often citing secretive elements of
Jesuit initiation and vows yeah they do
although largely speculative they say
the Jesuits intense focus on discipline
inner transformation and oath taking has
been interpreted as having a cult
undertones because it
does um so on this day it is connected
or has such close proximity to lugan
Assad or August August 1st which is
known as um a significant Pagan Festival
marking the beginning of the harvest
season this actually places ignatius'
Day within a season traditionally linked
to Fire Light and harvest which can
align with the Jesuit themes of
Enlightenment and service it has a
festival of light and fire many ancient
Traditions around Late July and early
August celebrate this as we've already
talked about so it actually um
connections with
that and he took the same Zeal that we
saw ignatious Loa took the same Zeal
that they said that Paul had to push
your beliefs and and go even into
military militaristic force to do so um
and have a blinders on type of way of
spreading your faith and force um so he
took that to heart he also was the one
who
made as as the um Society of Jesus is
known it also
became they're known for torture they
they practice and study methods of
torture Okay so so um Ignatius as a
spiritual Warrior he is acclaimed as a
former Soldier and dedicated to
spiritual
warfare um such as Mars he overlaps with
Mars in Roman mythology or the Norse god
Tire which is supposed to have Marshall
prowess and dedication to Divine causes
he supposedly took on that as
well um he was kind of a martyr or
whatever for his faith and he also
adapted all local beliefs to become syn
syncretic basically into Catholicism he
was probably one of the masterminds for
that all right so we are in
August this is Lamas or AKA lug nasad
like we've been pointed back to a little
bit once in a while it's been mentioned
Lamas or lug nasad celebrated on August
1st is one of the traditional Pagan
festivals in the wheel of the Year
observed primarily in Celtic and other
ancient European cultures its Origins
and themes revolve around the Harvest
honoring deities of Agriculture light
and abundance so lugan Asad marks a
beginning of the harvest season
particularly the grain harvest the name
Lamas is derived from Old
English uh halaas meaning loaf Mass
reflecting the tradition of baking the
first grains into bread as an offering
of
thanks it was a time to give thanks for
the crops and the abundance of the earth
often involving feasts where the first
loaves were shared in gratitude the gods
and Spirits associated with the land as
you can see is pretty well depicted
there um of course the word mass uh
hearkens back to all of the Pagan masses
or holidays that have been now become
Christ uh C Catholic that are on our
calendar there were games that were
associated with celebration and symbolic
Act of this involving
um luge's favor for strength and
vitality during the Harvest the first
fruits Loaves and sometimes small
animals or symbolic figures made from
grain stocks were offered to the gods
spirits and ancestors in things and to
ensure continued
Prosperity these offerings often
included bonfires where the first
sheaves of grain or bread were burned to
honor the gods and share in the earth's
Bounty bonfire symbolized the sun's
waning power as summer began to turn
towards Autumn as a Harvest Festival
Lamas is tied to fertility in the
earth's Cycles
of course we know what that goes with
abundance and fertility rituals to do
that it was time to recognize the
interconnectedness of Life Death and
rebirth acknowledging that the Earth's
sacrifices allow for the community's
survival luk nasad derives its name from
Luke a prominent Celtic god associated
with light skill and craftmanship lug
was not specifically a harvest God but
his skills and attributes were
celebrated during this time the festival
was said to have been founded by Luke in
honor of his foster mother t T who
according to Legend died after clearing
the land for agriculture thus the
festival also became a time to honor the
ancestors and those who labored for
communities
prosperity in addition to feasting lug
NAD was marked by Games sports and
contests to honor luges skills and
prowess these games were akin to the
Olympics with athletic contests horse
racing and comp competitions to Showcase
strength and
skill okay um the wiccans who follow
this are following the wheel of the year
because that's where it comes from it is
one of the eight sabbaths that they
follow like we are talking about inul
belain um and so on for wicens Lamas is
a time of gratitude abundance and and as
we saw they observe this day with
rituals that honor the first harvest
often baking bread and offering and
gratitude to the Earth and deity so that
would be like on their altar themes of
abundance we saw that um you can read
the rest of that if you want it's been
the same thing the Jesuits being a
Catholic order do not traditionally
celebrate Lamas as a pagan Festival
however Catholicism historically adopted
aspects of pagan seasonal festivals
which kind of hearken back to
it with Catholic Harvest Feast they
offer the first fruits and bread which
are
made um for the Jesuits bread has deep
significance in Eucharistic symbolism
the body of Christ while they do not
celebrate Lamas the symbolic import of
bread and sacrifice May align indirectly
with Catholic themes of gratitude for
God's
provision this connects a lot um
historical and symbolic ties Freemasonry
doesn't directly celebrate Lamas but
often explores ancient tradition symbol
symbols and cycles of nature that align
with the themes of the Harvest M
cultural and Community Values of course
they used it for this Freemasonry
appreciates this and tries to connect it
to community labor and gratitude values
that are woven into their philosophy
okay continue on with assumption day uh
which happens on August 15th through
16th it is a Catholic feast
commemorating the Assumption of the
Virgin Mary into heaven so they assume
that's what it means the
assumption that she went to
heaven does that sound bad to anyone
else um however it was already a pagan
festival and was honoring the goddess of
fertility Hest Harvest and motherly
protection which were celebrated around
mid August in various
cultures here is where it is it's um
tied to it's the Roman Festival of Diana
which is known as the Festival of the
Torches interesting that it has the
element of fire the mid August Festival
of Diana celebrated on August 13th was
dedicated Diana the Roman goddess of the
new the moon the hunt and
childbirth and and um Diana was often
viewed as a protective mother figure it
was worshiped with torches symbolizing
light and guidance Diana's Festival
aligns closely with themes of protection
and motherhood resonating with the later
veneration of Mary so they just made it
di Diana was the original and now she is
Mary okay it also lines with the Greek
goddess
deer and harvest themes um it's similar
to how
Mary uh she was similar because she was
the goddess the Greek goddess of harvest
fertility and
motherhood mid August celebration gave
thanks for the Earth's abundance similar
to how Mary is the Assumption of of Mary
is the assumption is venerated as a
protective mother
figure okay it also seems to overlap
with Fe feasts of Isis
in ancient Egypt where she was
associated with magic fertility and
motherhood
again
um the Catholic connection of Mary's
Assumption parallels the mythological
themes of Isis as sending to Divine
realm with her powers
intact reflecting protection and
continuity of Life aarte Queen of Heaven
um is also known in
ancient mythology for being the goddess
so fertility Love and War she is called
the Queen of Heaven and she's is
Assyrian and
Phoenician this title overlaps with the
Catholic title for Mary as Queen of
Heaven oh they like to emphasize that
don't they celebration of fertility and
harvest the stard day's worship involves
rituals for fertility and Bountiful
Harvest her worshippers often celebrated
her during Harvest times such as we're
seeing Alig with Mary's veneration in
late
summer um having the motherly qualities
Mother Earth as we said she is a mother
and she was also celebrating in late
summer as we see as the Abundant Giver
of Life and the sustainer of humility
Humanity festivals and offerings were
made to honor the Earth's Bounty and M
maternal care so Mary's Assumption day
Echoes all of these
themes and
um somehow she's always tied with this
harvest season
so that
is that but we also have August 24th St
Bartholomew's day which is called the
Great Wick and Sabbath and fire
Festival so this picture will make a lot
more sense later
but it is also known as St baral's day
in Catholicism as it connects with pagan
origins Wiccan traditions and their ult
practices particularly themes of Fire
Protection in the end of summer Harvest
this date aligns with themes celebrating
both Pagan fire festivals and Wiccan
sabbaths making it significant in
various spiritual Traditions St
Bartholomew's day and Pagan fire
festivals are connected on August 24th
is close to season turning from Summer
to Autumn and is time traditionally
marked by fire festivals and Pagan
cultures as we see we've been covering
that all along so it has the ties to
Lamas and lug nasad like we
covered um with a great Wiccan Sabbath
and fire connection celebration
connection fanction while not one of the
major eight
sabbaths in the wiccan wheel of the Year
August 24th has some significance for
wicens as a time of reflection and
spiritual preparation as a light begins
to fade Wiccan practitioners May hold
smaller rituals involving fire and light
to give thanks for the Summer's Bounty
and to keep protection for the coming
winter so they use um this is a day of
protection banishing and Wiccan and
Pagan practices this aligns with st
baram's themes in folklore where he is
believed to protect against evil forces
rituals may include burning herbs
lighting candles and invoking deities or
Spirits associated with safeguarding the
home and harvest
so here they have actually tied the the
reason that they burn certain things is
to actually activate the energy to make
it so basically with the demons or the
gods or basically give it power to
become
reality okay the occult significance is
there for some oult traditions late
August is seen as traditional
time where they can perform rituals that
honor this change a change of
from uh darker half of the Year
welcoming introspection and Shadow work
that's a not cult work or phrase it is a
time to prepare for the winter months
seeking inner strength and resilience
they use it as spiritual cleansing in
which they
do uh I guess just cleansing rituals
aimed at purging negative energy this
ties into the theme of purification is
sometimes incorporated into occult
rituals that reflect a spiritual reset
before a
Autumn historical and folklor
associations will St barol as a goodness
I'll start again St barthol as a
protector against evil in Catholic
folklore St bartholo was believed to
have power over demons and evil
spirits this aligns with Pagan practices
that seek protection from malevolent
forces especially as a Seasons shift
folk Traditions sometimes invoke St
barthol in practic in protection spells
or blessings reflecting an overlap with
similar Pagan
rituals he's also connected with healing
particularly skin diseases diseases
healing rituals are common during the
traditional periods in which Pagan and
Wicken Traditions with some practices
incorporating elements like sacred herbs
or fire to invoke health and
protection okay it also um aligns with
preparation for the fall equinox um that
is important to them which is mayin the
Fall Equinox and wika which celebrates
balance Gra gratitude and the Second
Harvest the period surrounding St
Bartholomew's day can act as a spiritual
preparation focusing on gratitude for
the light of summer in anticipation of
the darker more introspective season
ahead Harvest rituals Pagan and Wiccan
rituals near the end of the August May
focus on Gathering the last fruits of
Summer both physically and spiritually
celebrants give thanks for abundance and
prepare offerings to the land wow to the
land as a gesture of respect and
gratitude
this convergence of pagan Wiccan and oul
practices with the Catholic feast of St
bartholomeu reflects ancient traditions
of honoring the Earth's cycles and
preparing spiritually for the shifting
Seasons it aligns also with themes of
protection fire Harvest and trans
transition to Autumn and has connections
to various gods and goddesses such as
Diana she had the Festival of torches on
August 13th as we saw
um she had Harvest attached to
her lug as we saw as well
Isis and the Sirus and the dog star
healing as well festivals for Harvest
deer in the
Greek um as she overlaps with deer she's
known deer is known to be associated
with grain agriculture fertility was
honored in various Harvest festivals her
story particularly her grief over her
daughter peron's descent into the
underworld symbolizes cycle of life and
the coming of Darkness a theme present
in the late August rituals Harvest
themes are
everywhere in Hecate in the Greek she is
the goddess of magic the crossroads like
the crossroads that the actors and the
music artists go to to be honored by
Satan with gifts and
skills and protection heate often
involved invoked as his Guardian at the
crossroads repr represents both
protection and transformation not as the
goddess of Witchcraft and Magic her
influences increase increases as the day
shortens and the season shifts towards
Autumn supposedly protection and
purification they also invoke in Wiccan
and Pagan practic or practitioners they
invoke Hecate during the late August to
seek guidance and
protection they feel that her role as a
guardian against dark Forces resonate
with the cleansing and protection
rituals associated with this
time Bartholomew's Massacre I hope in
some ways that you have heard of this in
some ways that you haven't but St
baram's massacre massacre was a time the
marriage of Henry of
of naari a Protestant and Margaret of
valos a
Catholic which led to a dead deadly trap
for the hugenots or Christians of the
day the massacre began on August 24th
1572 after Catholic forces reportedly
under the influence of Katherine D Medi
and other powerful Catholic
leaders exploited the Gathering of
Protestants in Paris under the guise of
reconciliation the Catholics targeted
Protestant leaders beginning with
Admiral Gasper D kigy and swiftly
escalated to a city-wide Slaughter that
saw men women and children
massacred this betrayal spread across
France over several weeks resulting in
deaths of deaths of thousands of
hugenots and deepened the bitter divide
between Catholics and Protestants in
Europe the event is remembered as a
devastating example of religious
violence and political
manipulation but some groups such as the
Jesuits AKA Catholics actually
commemorate this day for having White
wiped out a fraction of Christians
getting in the
way and that is my research for that
this brings me back
to thanking you guys so much for your
patience and understanding that is all
for this deep dive part two please stay
tuned for part three you'll you'll enjoy
it as well and um of course if this is a
lot for you which it is for anybody I'll
just be honest take time to go through
it it and I hope to see you guys soon I
know Mikey went through all of um the
thank yous for how much we appreciate
you guys as our viewers and how to
support us and where to get our merch
thank you so much if you guys want to
support this ministry you can do so by
going to cash app candid truth official
vinmo my name Mikey Jenny zel execute
brand at
Gmail and check out our shirts man we
got some shirts and hoodies we got a lot
of cool designs and we're coming out
with new ones all the time and we're
doing the best we can as just two of us
actually Aubry has some skin care line
if you want to talk about that oh um
yeah so I recently launched a body care
line um mainly it consists of shampoos
and lotion and body wash right now I'm
working on a conditioner these are
important um because
when we think of clean products in our
grocery store or in
life we really don't have those I don't
know if you know that but I I uh
recently
became and have been for a little while
a functional nutritionist who cancels
people so if you want counseling go
ahead on my website it's
www.so
body.com and I have a Blog where you can
learn a little bit more um about stuff
but I was um influenced to make my own
body care line because I was already
doing so for myself and my family um
because I didn't want any of the
additives or preservatives or hormone
disruptors and um things that clog your
skin or just hurt them basically toxins
that you take into your body to affect
my health
anymore so you can also go up on um soob
body.com and go to the shop and check it
out we have all of those available to
you um we've already had quite a few
orders come in but I would love to have
more of you know about it and its
healthy benefits um so if you'd like a
clean body care line and you want to
honor God with your health um that's a
good alternative to a lot of what's sold
in stores even if they claim to be
organic or clean or vegan they usually
have waxes or parabens and all kinds of
other things that are not good for
you so that's my Spiel hope you guys
loved this um presentation and that
you'll check out my other website as
well